[Music]
did you ever think you were made
Sweet Victory I know this life meant for
me yeah why would you plan on Goliath
when we got bad David now you tame it
giving values contagious
[Music]
oh okay so we got a friend in the house
uh uh a man we love Dave Rubin how you
doing good to see you pbd I must say you
know I do a lot of these programs and
some people say I was a pioneer of the
podcast and going independent and all
that thing but you guys run an operation
I mean now we're in the we're in the
live studio yes you have to explain to
people why there's no one here but we're
all well the reason why is because this
building has how many ACS does this one
have 12 ACS the other one has one and
everyone is how 28 ton AC unit that we
have to bring from a whole different
place long story we wanted to be cool so
we decided to do it here man because we
don't want to be sweating the last
podcast we did we were sweating Vinnie
and Adam passed out at one point
you're going to be okay anyways Vinnie
strikes me as someone that sweats a lot
Middle Eastern yeah it's bad he's got
that Middle Eastern Oil Gene anyways
guys got a lot of topics to cover we
have to talk about your guy Governor
Rhonda yeah especially after this
weekend you know with the events that
happen at Turning Point USA and why he
didn't go to Turning Point USA and I'd
love to get your feedback on that and
what happened at the uh the blaze event
which was uh an incredible event what
Tucker did to a son what Tucker did to
Mike Pence potentially finishing off his
career I mean you know we'll talk about
a poll Iran on me having Vivek de santis
uh Tim Scott and Mike Pence on what
happened to it then I ran one with Vivek
against RFK what happened which was kind
of interesting and then a couple other
stories uh that we got one is the Border
some stuff is going on at the board we
want to talk about uh a story came out
from inside which I thought it was very
interesting because you know to them
they said what is micro aggression 15
things people think are fine to say at
work but are actually racist sexist or
offensive you actually have to read this
to see what people are saying with that
and then Ron Perlman calls out Studio
executive who said strike will cause
home losses be careful mother effort
we'll show this video with Ron Perlman
he seems like a very pleasant nice
sweetheart of a guy yeah great and the
person he's calling out 27 million
dollars you made 27 million dollars we
know who he's calling out uh uh I'll
point out why he said 27 million Rob
you're going to need to Google this when
we get to that point of what happens
there Europe's getting poor uh San
Francisco Mark benihoff who bought Time
Magazine and he owns Salesforce he says
San Francisco downtown is never going
back to the way it was uh home prices
are uh you know in uh interesting things
happen within Steep and uh sustained
decline this year is what an economist
from Fox Business is saying Tucker
Carlson's about to start a media company
I don't know if you've heard or not he's
raising money behind closed doors uh
Insider look at this uh beautiful
headline you ready uh the number of
views for Tucker Carlson's new show on
Twitter has dropped by 86 percent since
its launch and by the way it's absolute
fake news we'll we'll talk about that a
few other things about politics that's
going on but I say let's get right into
it with turning point us and FYI for
some of you guys that are watching we're
about to announce uh the next town hall
it'll be the first town hall we're doing
in this building I believe it's August
4th I think no it is August 4th we'll do
here Town Hall we got three more set up
after that but we'll be announcing the
first one
so for those of you guys that want to be
invited because it'll sell out like this
text award podcast to
310-340-1132 again text award podcast to
310-340-1132 at the end of the podcast
I'll announce who that person is and I
will shoot you a text for you to be able
to go buy the tickets but having said
that let's get right into it so
I had Charlie Kirk on a podcast yes okay
and you know Charlie you know you know
what he's done great job at a young age
on what he's built with Turning Point
USA they had you know apparently 7 000
people uh at the event unbelievable
turnout and I asked him I said Charlie I
saw your lineup of guests you know the
blaze had you know the santis they have
this they have that they have how come
you don't have the Santas why didn't you
invite the Santas and he said he did I
don't know if you've seen his response
or not I saw the podcast but do you
think you know Governor Ron descent is
not going to the Turning Point USA event
the criticism that Charlie Kirk gave
it's in your state it's in your backyard
why don't you go to it do you think it
was the right room not to go or do you
think he should have gone well first off
first off let me just say blanket before
we do anything else that I'm happy to
dive into absolutely any of this
whatever we may agree on disagree on
fight it out and well well we should and
you know one of the things that I think
frustrates people with mainstream media
is you don't know any of these people's
opinions you watch Jake Tapper and you
don't really know his opinions you have
an inclination as to what they are any
of these guys right so I think it's
important that you and I are upfront
about our opinions and then and then we
can hash it out uh in terms of going to
Turning Point or not I've gone to many
of those events it's it's a yearly event
they used to call it the student action
Summit I think they've rebranded it this
year look in essence it's a it's a trump
rally that's what it is that's the first
place I ever met Donald Trump uh ended
up going to Mar-A-Lago after spending
time with him that's one of the nights
that kind of converted me to be a a
trump supporter in the first place but
virtually everyone there is a hardcore
Trump supporter if I'm not mistaken
DeSantis did do it last year with Trump
they were both there last year uh as for
him not doing it this year uh look I
think it was was it the day before that
the blaze event was and Trump was not at
that so everyone has their own
calculations I think for DeSantis
probably optically it was a good move
not to go because you know you're going
owing to a trump base event where people
are going to go bananas for Trump and
they like you but they're going to be a
little afraid of applauding for you
because we know how rabid that base is
so I don't know that there's some
message that he couldn't get out
otherwise could he have shown up and
would he have done his usual thing sure
but I don't think it hits you either way
to be quite honest I actually think
Trump not going to the blaze thing was
far more damaging in terms of your
ability to get your ideas out there
because Tucker first off Tucker is
mostly a trump guy you know he's never
flat out said that he voted for Trump or
something like that he's criticized
everybody but yeah but he criticized but
you know especially on foreign
but I think that would have been really
interesting like if you want to see
Trump do a do an honest sit down with
someone where he's not just fighting
back and forth like he would on CNN or
something it's like Tucker's the guy
right so I think Trump should have been
there that to me strikes me as more of
of a missing piece than DeSantis at the
other so here's what I would say to that
for me uh it's naturally going to be a
trump event because Trump was a
president so I think if DeSantis was the
president and flipped this entire
scenario and turning point USA was
campaigning for the santis in 2015-16
they helped him and Trump helped pick up
Charlie Kirk when he said at 24 years
old he helped me and then 2020 becomes a
trump event because Trump was running
the sentence was in the picture flip it
it's 20 if 2016 was DeSantis and he
becomes president and then he goes and
helps Charlie Kirk and in 2020 it's a
DeSantis event of course the Turning
Point USA event would be a DeSantis
event and Trump would have to come to
enemy territory essentially but he would
have to do that because that's what you
want so if you look at whether I saw
Will Kane the other they asked the uh
this answers the question by the way
right now now the last thing you want is
for every single show to go to Every he
doesn't go to podcasts but he goes to
all these shows and he likes 10 minute
shows 20 minute shows the sentence and
even when we talk they're like yeah he
only likes 20 minute shows why do you
only like 20-minute shows why not do a
two-hour show why not sit down do a long
form so every one of the shows he goes
to what's the host asking the first
question hey what do you think about the
criticism the media has given you about
the fact that you are no longer and you
know no longer you know you're not
willing to go out there and talk to
people and all this stuff if 20 people
ask you that becomes a reputation so I
think for him uh uh I I would say the
other way around anywhere the leading
candidate goes is an honor for that
person to have them meaning the blaze is
lucky to have Trump because Trump is the
leading candidate but the scientists
showing up and saying yes to Charlie
Kirk which by the way here's the other
thing to be thinking about Charlie Kirk
let's think about it from this position
here how long will Trump I'm going to
talk very logical and we're going to
talk purely strategic nothing emotional
okay
um
who matters more over the next
how long is the Santa's plan going to be
in politics what do you think his
timeline is is it fair to say the center
is going to be in politics a lot longer
than Trump is oh for sure no question
about it can we say 20 30 years longer I
would say 30 years 50 years perfect let
me ask you a question whose lifespan is
longer in the political space not
literally lifespan although that can be
also calculated is Charlie Kirk going to
be in political space longer than Donald
Trump obviously yeah there's another
question about it of course it's going
to be Charlie Kirk right so to me when
you have somebody that's got a and maybe
Charlie has the most important vote of
the Republican party which is who the
guys in their 20s because you could have
that award for 40 50 years you don't
want to go there think about 7 000
younger people are sitting there saying
you don't want to come earn my vote I
don't know man I'm kind of offended that
could last 20 30 years so I don't know
if I'm a strategist behind closed doors
and we're having this conversation and
we're saying hey guys we're going to
choose between one of the two we got the
blaze which again Glenn Beck is one of
the guys that's on the Mount Rushmore at
his Peak he was a show nobody would ever
Miss he crushed it and uh he was the one
guy I met years ago I'm like this guy's
an incredible talent and he's a very
good communicator yeah but if you see
Turning Point USA to say you skip that
and it's a trump place that could have
been an opportunity to come in and give
a message and win their vote don't you
agree yeah I don't disagree with that
again we're not privy to all the
calculations of what anyone is doing on
any given day you know Trump said he had
some prior engagement for the for the
blaze thing so it's like everyone makes
their account regulations I think
there's winds to there's more winds to
showing up if you're if you're confident
in what you're doing then there's more
wins to showing up so as I said DeSantis
would have given a great speech the the
Applause probably would have been more
tepid than the Rabid Trump base because
turning point and again I've done plenty
of things with them I I like and respect
Charlie I've known him for for many
years in essence you know they're a
non-profit as I understand that they're
a non-profit that really is a trump
campaign fundraising organization like
there is some weirdness there and I
think maybe DeSantis didn't want to get
fully mixed up in that but I see I see
winds in showing up and I think your
point to DeSantis is obviously number
two he's not number one at the moment so
you gotta make some of those inroads and
uh we shall see how uh it continues you
make a good point because when I was at
the when I uh went to uh uh uh Turning
Point USA's 10-year anniversary
fundraiser uh some of the people there
were uh uncomfortable on the position
that they were taken with Trump because
some of the descendants guys were there
and like hey you know I don't know if I
want to contribute because I'm more
DeSantis I'm not Trump all this stuff so
that was an objection right that some of
the donors had to address I also I also
don't know all the legal ramifications
of when you're running a non-profit
that's a political non-profit you know
you can't directly endorse a candidate I
think they get as close to that I'm not
I'm not sitting here trying to start
nonsense I'm just saying like there is
there's always that fine line between
like oh we're putting these people up to
talk about their ideas and so that they
can express themselves versus yeah we're
tacitly endorsing them and in essence
raising money for them you know that's
that's a very fine line so so so for me
like I I think from the span of okay for
media we're going to be around for a
long time the only person I can fire us
is going to be the man upstairs that's
it so if I'm either dead or God says
you're done no problem I'm not doing it
this thing's going to continue on its
own back then it's going to do what it's
going to do but we're going to be
competing for the next 40 years yeah so
if we're going to be competing for the
next 40 years
it is
very imperative of us to look at young
Talent that's coming up that's
formidable that our True Believers that
are capable to say I think that guy
could one day be a superstar like for
example the Tucker moment when Jon
Stewart came to try to bully him you
know we've all seen that whole thing
Crossfire and he's trying to bully him
yeah and in that moment I just want to
know when Tucker got off stage what did
he tell himself that night or his best
friend or his wife if he was married at
the time or his girlfriend or his family
what did he say to them did he say
something like I'm gonna kill this guy I
want to know that because oh I bet you a
nugget was planted because that was a
seminal moment
if you talk about Jon Stewart and Tucker
maybe mainstream some people wow you
know it's John stood all this stuff but
Tucker's in a whole different level it's
not the same league also by the way Jon
Stewart has become far more of what he
was accusing Tucker of than Tucker right
because they were sitting on CrossFire
yes and Stewart basically walked on that
set and said you are the reason talking
to Tucker you are the reason for
political partisanship and hackery and
the hatred and blah blah blah and it's
like who actually has added more to that
in the last decade I would say Jon
Stewart has been a far worse Arbiter of
those things than Tucker Tucker actually
if you if you escape what the mainstream
media says about Tucker Tucker is
constantly talking about crossing the
Divide he's trying to talk about what
populist things will bring us both
together talking about his actually
classically liberal Roots constantly
John is the one who's gone completely
bananas left so there's been a real
shift in there and I wonder that would
be a great conversation for them to have
that would be a phenomenal conversation
for the tutorial but okay so you know I
watched uh the governor on uh Fox a
couple days ago I don't know who he was
but he was with somebody it was a 15
minute clip I watched and the the
gentleman interview him he he's somebody
that people who watch Fox should know
who this guy is he is very good at what
he does but uh he asked a lot of good
question and hey you know what are you
going to do with this and what are you
going to do with that and and then
DeSantis kept going back the Republican
voter knows this and you know Iowa we've
spent this and in Iowa we're doing
meetings and people are showing up we
were having some meetings that was 30 40
people and you know
when you say stuff like that and it's
like well what do you think about the
fact that you know some people are
claiming you're not a marketer you don't
know how to sell the campaign you don't
know how to do this what are your
thoughts on on that well you know if you
look at it you know I'm here to do a job
and if you look at what I've done in
Florida do you think we are seeing and
witnessing where the whole idea of what
Nixon uh lost to John F Kennedy years
ago because Nixon was a very qualified
candidate more qualified than John F
Kennedy Nixon was essentially a Ron
DeSantis forget the Watergate example
just set that part aside where Nixon had
to learn how to go be a little bit more
of a showman yeah more presentable and
he had to go work with some people
behind closed doors do you think that's
a fair criticism that Ron is getting in
do you think that's going to hurt him or
do you think no I think it's irrelevant
he can he still has a shot well you know
last time we sat on this very stage
which was probably about four months ago
uh you brought that up that there's a
marketing issue with DeSantis to me
that's uh and I'll repeat what I said
that time and then I'll give you a new
Twist on it to me that's a very solvable
problem I think what you want out of a
candidate are two things you want
basically does this guy roughly believe
in the things that I believe in
politically are we do we have enough
stuff that we kind of agree on that I
can support this guy and then do you
think that this guy can accomplish it
that's that I think is the bigger one
now because I think we have a lot of
people who say the right things but can
they actually do it now in my estimation
obviously DeSantis checks those two
boxes does is there some level of a
marketing thing well look he has not
done your show he absolutely should do
your show so I don't know where you guys
are at internally with that but he
should uh you know just yesterday I
think they announced that he's doing
Megyn Kelly finally now she's been very
critical of him partially because he has
not done her show it's a great move to
go on that show uh he's going on uh Jake
Tapper today uh at four yeah so so that
is an interesting moment he go you know
he's basically his position with the
mainstream media has basically been you
guys lie about everything I'm not going
to play your game as opposed to Trump
where it's you guys lie about everything
I'll constantly play your game but now
he's realizing okay I gotta get in on
that so we'll see what happens with him
and Tapper I would love to see the guy
go on Rogan he should he should just say
offhand he should say hey I'll do Rogan
why not why wouldn't I do that
three-hour thing not just the the
20-minute thing he should sit down with
those harpies on The View and let them
say all of the crazy BS nonsense
or is it is it fear no I don't I don't
think I forget the answer but is it fear
is it somebody behind closers holding
back or is it I'm too good for that no
well well first off again I'm not
understanding for yourself I'm just
giving you my opinion on this I think
they're running a campaign and everyone
runs the campaign a little bit
differently I think they probably wanted
to test the waters when he announces we
believe this is the best guy he's sort
of the most functional and competent
let's see what happens what it does to
the polls now it clearly did not do to
the polls what they wanted so now they
have to dive in in a little bit of a
different way as I've been saying on my
show for weeks now do you know you know
the first debate is not till August 23rd
so we're still a month away from the
first debate do you guys know when the
first votes are cast the first primary
do you have any idea well it's August
23rd of Milwaukee that's that's the
first no no that's the first debate
that's right do you know when the first
primary is do you have any idea it's
January so we are still basically seven
months away from votes being cast in the
first Primary in Iowa so this this meme
out there that he has to drop out now
and it's such crazy nonsense no no no no
not you not you but you get this from
the Trump people now it's like he better
drop out to save his political
agreements Dave you're saying there's a
lot left game to be played of course
we're still early in the first quarter
we're literally seven months away from
the front we're not even in we're in the
pregame of the pregame we're in the
locker room before the pregame and all
of those pieces have to fall into place
so I think they were trying to do a slow
burn and to your point as marketing and
to your credit by the way this is
exactly what you said three months ago
and you were right because it has not
lit fire uh you gotta you gotta change
tactics I think the Tapper thing today
is going to be my gut feeling is
something interesting is going to happen
there that might shift the The Narrative
a little bit because what he needs he
needs a little bit of the RFK juice
whether whether I agree with RFK on
everything or not and I had him on my
show last week it's like he's got some
of the Zeitgeist stuff I think what
DeSantis is missing people know he's
competent they know he's he's a good
governor and all that stuff but it's the
Zeitgeist thing that that gets you to
the all the pieces you're talking about
like how do you Market that and and with
RFK there's the policy stuff which is
some love it some highly dislike it
there's also the personality stuff it's
sort of two sides of the coin you see I
5K pumping those weights yeah like takes
a shirt off it's like what is this guy
running for the next Hulk Hogan or what
is he doing the Santa says challenge is
certainly not a policy thing
in my opinion which we've discussed it's
a personality thing it's a marketing
thing the guy played baseball at Yale
yeah dude get out there throw the ball
around hit a home run hit a Dinger do a
Big Poppy walk around the bases like be
real yeah what people love about Trump
this dude he'll get out there and give
you that strong handshake how you doing
I mean he's out there he's no it's
incredible you're running against a
marketing genius arguably one of the
greatest marketers of all time and
you're missing the marketing game that's
the biggest you know I would also I
would also so I do agree with that and
the funny thing about Trump is it's like
he's the fakest person in the history of
the world and also the most authentic
it's amazing how we can do both that
that really is probably
fake as the realest guy you've ever met
in your life which one is it I don't
know either he's literally a non-human
color with that crazy hair that's the
fakest thing you can imagine and then
his lifestyle and all of those things
have nothing to do with the ordinary man
and then yet obviously what you're
saying and from when the times I've been
with him there there's a real human in
there and that's the thing that I think
people are trying to connect to DeSantis
you know it's also like in some ways
it's sort of why we end up probably
where we're at politically and why
politics in the modern world almost
can't work because we're sort of asking
for a best friend and a father and a bro
and whatever and it's like I have
friends and I have a father and I have a
brother so I'm not really looking for
all of that I'm looking for a competent
executive and and I think that that's
important but yes should he get out
there and I want to see the guy in a
t-shirt I've said that to them like get
the he should show up in to Rogan in a
t-shirt not in a suit but just or with
you or or just like some of that I guess
be real the first time I I the first
time I ever met him uh in person where
we actually spent some time together
one-on-one was uh backstage when I did a
show with him last June and we had about
a half hour and all he wanted to talk
about actually was baseball and my buddy
who was joining me on toward my body man
he's a baseball player too so they they
totally hit it off talked about and it
was like that is the thing that I think
people are kind of looking for I think
that that's what you're looking for it's
certainly what you're looking for and I
just think patience you know everyone
wants everything at once Dave I hear
yeah it's a long game we're in the
second inning to use a baseball analogy
but there's also missed opportunities so
he played baseball at Yale the guy's an
athlete he's a stud he was a navy jacket
officer it was just the MLB All-Star
Game
dude get out to the all-star game give a
little you know throw on the mound
whatever it is just be real and then
people can be like yo I don't even know
he played baseball yeah amazing again
players do some BP that's what's missing
and I do agree fully that it's a long
race debates are coming up in months and
you said that the first vote is cast in
January but you're also missing these
opportunities for the average guy to be
like oh I didn't know that he played
baseball well I didn't know that he's a
real yeah and you guys said like
marketing Donald Trump out of nowhere
like when we were at the UFC shows he's
almost 80 years old you look back at
midnight you're like is he is he here
yeah and he's been doing that and then
you actually nailed it on Pat Charlie
Kirk you put it you called them out on
you didn't call them out but when
Charlie cook was like I call Trump this
isn't accessibility call Trump two rings
hey what's up yep I'll be there bye
click they go we couldn't even get to
descendants you know I saw Charlie say
that and with all due respect that's
slightly nonsensical he's in it with
Trump so and there's all that money
there in the fundraising and as I said
turning point is basically a campaign
arm so it's a little uh disingenuous but
if they could Charlie yeah it's a little
disingenuous to be like oh I can get the
guy that I've been on the on the
campaign with for six years on the phone
I can't get to Santa's like it would be
easier for me to get to santis than
Trump but that doesn't prove that
DeSantis is more accessible you know you
really appreciate that Dave but like if
it was just Trump DeSantis but he also
did mention yeah I got an RFK running
the line I got Nikki Haley and then I
got Tim Skyline he's developing a
narrative is that like listen we're
people that were like we want you to win
we want you to do well he's developing A
Narrative of not showing up of sort of
playing like uh playing it safe playing
prevent defense and if you just look at
the polls the look at the polls look at
the polls it was neck and neck in
February and now it's a four to one lead
you know National National polls
actually mean nothing you guys know that
absolutely nothing you have to win a
couple primaries and I think he's going
to do really well in Iowa
I think he's going to do well in New
Hampshire then South Carolina comes
South Carolina is going to be the
wackiest of all of them because assuming
well Nikki will certainly be in it but
assuming Tim Scott is still in it that
thing's going to get split in a lot of
weird ways so it's very possible Trump
comes out and he's over five right at
the beginning because of some weird
things so that's why I'm saying everyone
just has to you know I know it's sort of
like we're all in the talking class and
everyone's obsessed with the and by the
way we can talk about Vivek too who
obviously has had a nice couple days
um but I just think you know there's a
tortoise in the hair situation here and
everyone has to kind of be patient but I
get it from the marketing perspective I
fully get your perspective listen policy
wise yeah we've said this over and over
we're here because of him yeah yeah like
this isn't a the both of you by the way
yeah
Arizona
AOG no shots here taken about Palace
which is what matters yeah which is what
matters the policies is what matters but
my God you need help to sell the
policies to others I have guys I'll
never forget so at the beginning when I
started running a business I would I
recruited this one guy his last name I'm
not going to say I'll say his first name
Steve okay he was a cop and he comes in
and I'm looking I'm like oh my God this
guy's going to be an incredible
salesperson for us he's going to kill it
he's he was in his mid 40s good looking
guy Blue Eyes in shape would run all
this stuff I'm like this guy's gonna
kill it first week he gets his insurance
license second week he gets a 6 and 63.
third week he gets his PNC license
fourth week he gets his real estate
license by the 20th week he's got 26
licenses
has not sold a single recipe for
disaster
think about every product all the
technical stuff but had no clue how to
sell it we would sit him in front of a
client and we would say sell couldn't do
it he would freeze I would say sell me
there is no camera close the door let's
role play he couldn't do it these were
these are these are types of things
where somebody for me
um does he have a marketing team does he
actually have a marketing and a PR team
I don't know okay I don't know so I
would I would I would probably
immediately hire somebody to give three
different perspectives you know story
came out about how Kim Kardashian that's
a weird story for me to give it was like
I thought I was fashionable until I
started dating Kanye and one day Kanye
comes in her closet and he looks at the
closet and he says you have no taste
well all you do is you wear what
everybody else tells you to wear because
you're following the fashion and the
trends he says he takes all her clothes
out of her closet trashes it she says
like we can't really get ready do I have
to really throw it away you have to
throw all of this stuff away he gets rid
of all her stuff and says I'm gonna fill
it up wow and you're gonna be a
trendsetter he brings it in Kim goes
from being a girl that was known for
being famous party and all this Ray J
all this stuff all of a sudden Kim is
now a fashion Nova people are now watch
of what she wears to go so meaning
it can be fixed yeah but you got to
bring a marketing person behind closed
doors that's the only thing that's
missing and I don't know if they want to
do that they they they're one you know
how you and I like basketball we're both
Sports and you look at the team you're
like Miami man they're one piece away
they need one guy Jimmy's a dog they got
a good team but they need one more guy
right Vincent went to LA but they need
one more time okay I don't know if he's
the guy but we'll see he needs one more
person you look at certain teams they're
like one away one away one away
I think the santis is one move away it's
a brilliant Market or behind closed
doors to just say Let's test this didn't
work what do you want who are you what
matters to you can you tell me what you
like what do you like stop saying here's
what America likes no what do you like
what are your interests what's your
style of parenting tell me about your
family tell me about this someone's got
to draw that out of a minute again I
think that's an absolutely Fair
criticism I would also say there's
something weird going on here with the
internet in terms of how we respond to
good and bad meaning if you watch the
the Forum The Blaze Forum right what
were the clips that really went viral it
was Tucker demolishing ASA Hutchinson
who nobody cares about right the guy was
polling at negative six he's done what
was the other clip that went viral it
was Tucker demolishing Pence right so
that goes viral now if you watch if you
watched uh Tucker sit down with Nikki
and uh and DeSantis specifically there
were no flubs so those clips don't go
viral you basically how many of the
DeSantis Clips with Tucker did you see
the scent is the good one no no she did
great that's my point but they don't go
viral because nobody's interested in
viral oh
it was good but I disagree but I decided
but that's just the nature of the
internet but listen Okay we do marketing
stuff or professionally right so there's
a there's an art and you it's not like
you got uh 200 000 followers you got
millions of followers and you're
everywhere right okay so you also know
it like if we talk marketing behind
closers you're like here's what works
SEO okay
you can go simply on tikta on YouTube on
Google right now type in
phrases that makes Tick-Tock videos to
go viral just just Google that I don't
know just search phrases that make
videos on Tick Tock go viral it's a lot
of times
okay 50 Tick Tock now go to the next one
go to the next one if you look at
someone's 175 best captions for record
100 Tick Tock captions
how to make viral okay so for example
you open up something and say let me
tell you what I just saw earlier today
and if you see this you're going to be
blown away by it right boom and it's
what is this song any of you tell
stories there's an R to storytelling
there's R2 creating controversy or
getting people to be curious about what
you got going on by the way it's not
hard to teach selling can be taught
communication can be taught creating
curiosity can be taught that is an area
they have to make investment I don't
want to beat the dead Horseman
I just want to say but but
he nailed all this like today he's doing
something maybe this is that like six
month Mark where now like they're
they're saying okay now let's start it
can you pull up that article you found
about Kim Kardashian and Kanye West I I
just saw it at the end it was phenomenal
until uh it was too late it was crazy
with Margie Simpson he says Kanye
compared Kardashian to to march to Marge
Simpson was called Kim Kardashian and
told her that her career was over when
he first saw one of her outfits that he
hadn't styled and compared her to Marge
Simpson can you imagine that and then
you know when she wins the award what
she says she hurt her in her speech she
says I never understood style and
fashion until I started dating Kanye he
changed the way I viewed and Kim is now
the modern day some people are going to
say she's not you can pick and choose
whether it's her or Margot Robbie or you
know whoever Marilyn Monroe Marilyn
Monroe you know like a Elizabeth Taylor
type of a figure anyways I don't see why
you have to throw Marge Simpson under
the busy
degree on Marge Simpson Dave is right
can you pull up the poll we ran this
last week on Twitter the two polls the
first one being uh the the which one was
it no the other one can you pull up the
other poll yeah so here's a poll I did I
said which these four candidates has
your vote today and this was July 15th
wow this is after Vivek had some
momentum at turning point us a lot of
momentum at Turning Point USA 85 000
people voted it's not a million votes
but it's it's a good amount of numbers
right there and this is after Pence
screwed up with what he said it's none
of my concern Pence goes 2.1 I
intentionally didn't put Chris Christie
because I wanted to see if this Tim
Scott is really a possible VP candidate
for Trump because you probably read this
it is a name that's being brought up Tim
Scott went to four percent the Santa's
36 vivec 58 so then a lot of people say
well how come RFK is not and this how
come Trump's not in this I'm
intentionally not putting Trump or Biden
that's obviously intentional those guys
are the guys that are the the lead dogs
right now favorite then pull up the
other one RFK versus vivec and this one
was interesting wow in the last 24 hours
54 000 voted and it's by a what is it
1.4 margin what made you put those two
very interesting Dynamic right there
first of all a lot of people will say
well your audience is conservative and
your audience is this well no look a
Democrat beat out a conservative well so
that's why this is this one this one
strikes me as as way more interesting
because obviously like like my audience
your audience is going to lean right
let's say I'm sure they're all over the
place politically but basically leaning
right and that's what's so interesting
about RFK which is what I'm saying
DeSantis has to do he has to capture
some of the Zeitgeist that RFK has so I
had RFK on last week and you know he
gets into how he was at a party with
Hillary Clinton like a month ago where
she said to him behind closed doors why
don't you get out of the way we all want
Biden like that's juice that's something
that people want to talk about that's
what Hillary yeah he said many people
say it to me even Hillary Clinton at a
party I think he said on the upper east
a couple weeks ago so like those types
of things like you know Hillary said
it's Hillary okay yeah kind of like the
DNC said it's a Bernie in 2016. just get
out of the way Bernie yeah we want
Hillary and by the way if you don't get
out of the way they will put you out of
the way so which is very comfortable and
familiar with these types
also has a similar phrase move blank get
out of the way get out the way the thing
is with with RFK I asked him right at
the beginning I told him right up front
uh I said I'm not sure how much you know
about my politics but I used to be you
know a traditional liberal and a
Democrat and all that I cannot associate
myself with the Democrat Party member
said why are you still a Democrat and he
kind of fumbled I like him a lot we had
a great conversation but he sort of
mumbled and fumbled through the
beginning of the answer he doesn't know
from what I can tell he does not know
why he's a Democrat anymore other than
his name is you think he's a Democrat
well he's running as a Democrat do you
think he's a Remnant no I think what he
is in essence is he's somewhere roughly
where I am which is that he's a
disaffected liberal who who in many ways
is a Libertarian and then has some use
of the government yeah so he's an old
school I know for the most part another
type for great people which in essence
in my view that means you really have to
vote for republicans and you're on what
I would say is the more moderate wing of
the Republican side but but that's a
whole other thing but I thought it was
interest he also told me that he has had
no contact with the Democrat Party now
get that think about that when you talk
about how they'll move you out of the
way this guy's pulling at 20 some odd
percent his name is Kennedy he's getting
a lot of juice in in our world and he
has had no they will not take his car
what surprising is that though no it's
not surprising at all it's lucky if they
don't kill him Dave I was saying if if
this was the 70s he found
you ever seen a documentary of a bush
senior and How It Ends the end of the
Bush type in George Bush Senior Ross
Perot if you type in in in YouTube if
you type in George Bush Senior Ross Pro
he's being asked questions about a lot
of different people Ross Pro ruined his
career well and at the end he says so
he's being it's a very nice documentary
everything's going smooth it's going to
be hard to find it I mean it's the end
of the documentary I'll find it on
Twitter and I'll retweet it so he said
so uh uh President Bush what do you have
to say about Ross Perot oh
I don't want to talk about that man
I don't want to talk about I don't want
to talk about it and he gets it's the
only time in the document it's in the
last five minutes of the documentary
where he gets angry talking about Ross
Perot literally cost him the election in
uh 92. yeah and by the way RFK is
literally going to cause Biden and
everybody on the Lefty election Biden is
senior RFK could be if he runs third
party you men he will he has no choice
because here's what's going to happen
let me kind of go through with you so
here's a guy that's with him last week
RFK we had a very good conversation
together two weeks ago he and I
I said you crush it on news Nation
absolutely on every issue you were
unbelievable and he says thank you for
the call and uh but if you if you think
about it Dems are not calling you okay
why would they call you so what are you
going to get your support from
you can't you know hey Charlie says hey
why don't you come and talk to Turning
Point USA you saw his answer he says hey
I don't know if you know or not I'm
running as a Democrat not as a
Republican
okay so I get it because if he goes his
concern is everybody in the mainstream
media is going to say he's a closet
Republican that's what they would have
you put him as he knows what the games
are going to be here this is a guy
that's a pretty strategic guy I kept
thinking he's just saying the things
that I thought five years ago about
myself like oh if I talk to those people
too much you only has one option yeah
and but by the way he's not a republican
he's not no he's not he's not abortion
climate change not a republican yeah you
know even affirmative action he's not a
republican right you saw what he said we
got into it what happened the other day
with the other stuff the clip maybe
we'll show the thing that's hurt him
this this week with what the cause of
coven and all this stuff he can get some
commentary on that as well but to me he
is a Libertarian classical liberal is
who he is and for a guy like him
the moment they oust him do you think
RFK comes across as a guy that just
disappears and goes and on his in his
own way and you know on his own and just
kind of retires and doesn't do anything
and goes to the gym and works out at
Gold's Gym no he'll do that but he'll
still say the guy who went after the
number one guy that everybody was afraid
of going after which was Antonio fauci
and he writes a book about him okay and
not any book A book that blows up and
gets viral with all research and nobody
nobody went and said well this is
inaccurable this is inaccurate it was
all research studies nobody could try
but I was like don't talk about that
yeah
this guy did with AIDS and how much
money doing a good kid so okay now you
want to go against him NIH CDC all that
stuff you think this guy's favorite
anybody this guy's got brass balls is
what he's got he's going to run as an
independent and whoever the Republican
candidate is going to be this guy's
going to be their number one Ally
let me let me just question one thing
because I could be wrong I'm just
telling you my gut feeling is he's not
going to run as an independent but I
will give you the I will give you the
future for him what I think is an actual
positive future and I think I might have
uh planted a seed with him when we
chatted that the reason I don't think he
will is I think I think he so believes
he he's struggling to realize what the
Democrat Party is but that thing the
Kennedy Democrat thing is so in his
blood I think he would struggle with the
idea of sort of being the guy that
destroyed the Democrat Party as a as an
independent run but how about this how
how about this one for you if you want
that good out for him how about because
I asked him at the end of our interview
I said you know we know your feelings
about Trump we know your feelings about
Biden what do you think about DeSantis
and he basically for three minutes right
at the end of the interview gave a
beautiful uh all the reasons why he
thinks DeSantis is great with kovid
lockdowns all of that stuff then at the
end I could sense suddenly he was like
oh [__] I just said too many good things
about a republican I better say
something and then he kind of in a very
flippant way was like but he's mean like
that was the that was the thing he
throws a baseball like a girl right
exactly like he needed to do something
right he suddenly was like I got to do
something because he's a republican I'm
a Democrat now I don't think he actually
really believes it I think it was just
what what sort of came out of his mouth
at that moment but here's the here's the
out for him because I don't think it's
going to be third party the out is now
imagine you have DeSantis as president
whoever the VP is it's not going to be
RFK you have whoever the BP is how about
he brings on RFK to do exactly what RFK
has done for the last 40 years years
which is attack these agencies and blow
apart the agents as a VP no not as VP so
you bring in whoever is VPI I think it
could be Kim Reynolds is my gut feeling
but it doesn't matter Again Jim Reynolds
for VP as to Santa I definitely think
that's possible but putting that aside
if you bring him on as the let's call it
the Czar of the
demolishing the agencies he's going to
be the guy that goes to NIH he's going
to be the guy that goes to CDC he's
going to be the guy that goes to the
Department of Education the guy who has
been a lawyer fighting these monsters
for so many years and that's the exact
job you give him and it's also somewhat
apolitical so you don't have to agree
with him on abortion you don't have to
agree with him on climate change Etc et
cetera I think that's something he would
Relish in doing uh in order for that to
happen uh the great the greatest
Governor during kobit has to fully
commit to being a better marketer
because there's zero chance that'll
happen if he goes the way he's going
today and I'm telling you right now
remember the phrase I said I didn't say
zero chance it's going to happen I said
zero Chance is going to happen if he
goes the way he's going today right so
that brings us to the earlier
conversation so that's so for me now
let's say that doesn't happen Okay let's
just say Trump is a nominee because
right now after Turning Point USA 85
some of the polls let's just say he's
got he's got a big lead whatever 72
that's like going to an Elvis fan club
and asking how many of you like Elvis
more than Frank Sinatra put up the polls
right now anyways pull up the polls
right now I'll make one quick point
about RFK and it kind of goes back to
your point that you were making with
George W bush and Ross Perot in 92 and
essentially playing spoiler and the
conversation about running as a third
party we don't think he's going to do it
but he might do it the third party
situation at Libertarians you get the
green party Andrew Yang the Ford party I
don't know what's going on with that how
familiar you guys with what's going on
with this no labels party it's starting
to pop up in conversations and a lot of
private Equity guys I guess have pumped
in
100 million dollars whatever the crazy
number is
it's the the they're going to kind of
see how it goes and they're going to
look at
who's the nominees and they're going to
sort of pick a Republican and a Democrat
or they're going to do a Democrat
Republican and sort of torpedo who they
don't want to win how familiar with this
situation I know a little bit about them
I mean they've been around for a while
it seems to be getting a little bit of
scene right now but these things happen
every couple years and nothing really
happens with it it sort of reminds me of
like a Yang kind of situation where it's
like Yang all along all the sort of
liberals who weren't complete woke
Maniacs we're all like I support Andrea
because it was the easiest simplest
thing to do instead of saying you
support Trump or you're just not going
to vote Democrats so these organizations
kind of come around every now and again
a few people who don't really want to
make a decision about anything because
they want to go to nice parties they
support it and then nothing nothing
everything you're kind of nodding
yourself
okay guys Andrew Yang vanilla we had him
on the podcast I'm like dude why do you
say something it's boring listening to
you right now so what happened you sound
boring I don't know if you remember this
or no yeah but he'll give you minimum
wage so that's good say something
John Kasich vanilla yeah Andrew Yang
vanilla uh uh you go to any of these
candidates that just want to say the
right things you know to kind of Mike
Pence right now
establishment language is what he's got
okay so if you go to some of these names
the one thing with RFK that's very
different and with Ross Perot that's
very different both of these guys are
100 True Believers yes they're not
acting there is no acting with RFK RFK
is like this is who I am listen as an
Environmental Lawyer
this is the guy that if he's gonna sue
you this is RFK if he sues you you know
who he is you know how sometimes most
lawyers they want to sue you what do
they do lazy lawyers what do lazy
lawyers do they set up a meeting hey man
look my clients got this you're probably
not going to get this it's probably
going to be three years over this and
the good example why don't we settle
this for two years I know half a million
dollars that's what lazy lawyers do and
90 of lawyers are lazy they just want to
settle behind closed doors then you have
the 10 then you have the one percent
then you have the 0.1 percent of the
Annoying lawyers RFK is that annoying
lawyer you don't want to go up against
any exposed found how many hours do you
think he spent writing that book to
research everything he possibly can on
fauci so the reason why I'm saying this
when a person put that much time
business owners there's going to come a
time when you run a company that you hit
a Breaking Point and this breaking point
is the final it's like playing a a poker
yeah you're playing poker and you're
like all right you're slow play you're
like yeah yeah yeah [__] ah 50 you know
River
yeah I'll go again another one and then
comes the river and you don't know if
the guy hit it because you missed it but
you got a nice decent pair but you don't
know if the guy hit the river he got his
flush or the straight or whatever maybe
right
you have to sit there you got to be like
you either
like yeah I'm good I'm out or you're
okay I'll call you
RFK is all in
there is no going back with RFK this is
not a guy that's having somebody telling
him what to tell the world RFK doesn't
have a marketing guy telling him say
this say that say this he's such a True
Believer and fearless that he's telling
you what he believes in and he doesn't
give a [__] if you like it or not he's
exposing these guys there is something
very attractive by the way
marketing isn't about yeah Tony Robbins
and you can do it that's not marketing
RFK with his voice
but because he's going so deep in the
way he exposes everybody that is a form
of marketing and storytelling and
exposing I think this guy is going to go
the Democrats are going to trash and I
think the Democrats haven't even started
with the whole demonizing of addict
heroin did you know this ex-wife I don't
think they've even started yet like
they're gonna start in about six to 12
months watch when they start trashing
RFK saying stuff that's so embarrassing
they're just hanging on to that and
they're going to make the call you know
what he's going to say he's gonna say go
right ahead man you guys have played
this on me for a long time he's not
going to let them do that and then
when behind closed doors he's by himself
and he's not on the debate stage with
Biden and he's going to be by himself
sitting there saying this mother you
killed my dad you killed my uncle
28 years old I went through a 14 year of
dealing with drugs because what you guys
The Establishment did to ruin my family
and look what you've done now you've
divided my own sisters publicly calling
me out no problem watch I'm doing this
now for my dad you guys killed I get the
chills thinking about that fire you
can't fabricate that fire when I look at
RFK I see that fire it's very unique
it's not a can you give me the 17
scripts on what to say to hit this point
hit this point he's not that guy this is
a True Believer so this is why I believe
for him it would be a shame and I'll say
this if he's watching this it would be a
shame if the Democrats don't give him
the stage and the time to sell his times
like yeah get out of here just want you
to step it out like Hillary Clinton step
out of the way like they did to Bernie
Elizabeth Warren all those other guys
it would be a shame if he didn't run as
a third party it would be a shame if I'm
a betting man
I would be so disappointed if RFK didn't
run as a third party I would be so I
would be so disappointed and surprised
if he didn't eventually run as a third
party you have to they're not going to
give you the stage time and your message
has to be heard by everybody there's a
reason why you're doing so well there's
a reason why when you talk
he goes on a podcast like oh go on the
way I Gidget I'll go on YouTube right
um
so I'll say all right let me see how
that guy did as an interviewee as a
guest not interview work right how do
you do as a guest because some people
are very good interviewers but they're
not good guests you can go on a guess
nobody wants to watch your podcast
because once they watch one or two of
your videos it's the same stories they
kind of know what you are You Can't Give
opinions on this and this and this and
go seven layers deep on financing six
layers deep on politics and family and
this and like we already know what you
stand for it's done right
and you go on YouTube I'll go on Fox and
I'll say okay the sentence is on how
many views 160 000 views
720 000 views and vivec was getting 30
000 views then it was getting 40 000
views now 280 000 views interesting so
RFK 2.8 million 2.2 million 1.6 million
and he talked about this and he talked
about this
guys it's so difficult to compete with a
True Believer and again if I am a
betting man
he's going to run as a third party all
he's thinking about is dad and his uncle
and the legacy of the men who came
before him that they killed him the
establishment killed his dad and his
uncle two of his Heroes they killed that
doesn't go away that doesn't go away and
sometimes in a family you know it's like
a crisis takes place you don't know
which of the guys like you almost have
to kill everybody in that family because
that's gonna stay and they killed they
didn't kill this guy sometimes you kill
the wrong guy and you're like yeah we
have to be careful with that guy don't
worry that guy just wants the girls yeah
he just wants to be on cover magazines
that guy in the back that you didn't
kill was the one that loved Mom Dad
Legacy more than anybody else you
screwed up and guess what 30 years later
wake up call he's been waiting for this
moment that's what I think I think the
key part of what you're saying is can he
have that come to Jesus moment with the
Democrat Party can he really fully
realize that's gonna happen when no no
I'm saying can he have the moment where
he realizes how evil it is and then
makes the move that you're saying
because again having just interviewed
him when I even when I talked to him
about affirmative action he it was very
clear to me you know because he was
against the decision so meaning he's for
affirmative action which to me is
systemic racism if you look at a bunch
of people by their skin color and decide
who can go to what college or get what
job Etc which I disagree with I
completely disagree I made my feelings
here but but it was interesting
listening to him rationalize it because
he was using a lot of old Democrat logic
meaning oh well I grew up in Jim Crow
South and I know what it was like that
he says all of that gives you all of
that and I know that the Democrats were
fighting for the black people and all
that and then but when he gets us now to
2023 he's like but you know you don't
really solve uh former discrimination
with current discrimination and I
actually get your point Dave and I don't
feel very strongly about this so he's
struggling he's having that's his
internal struggle that probably sits
right next to everything that you just
laid out there I want to burn these
mfers down but I also still have these
weird associations with the party that
my father basically built so that's uh
he's one of the most that's a challenge
he is like when the Democrats go to
sleep at night and they fear one person
if I were to put top three names on that
list one of them is RFK today they can't
stand him they fear Him they're so
annoyed by him they they hate the
attention he's getting they hate the
fact that he's loved the one thing that
all these guys can't get he's getting
why do they love him so much I'm more
important don't they realize I'm a
president he's not even a president I'm
the guy that made it to the top why do
you guys love him more than I'm Hillary
Clinton why are you guys giving him so
much attention people are not realizing
that there's a big difference between
those who planned on one day becoming a
president like a Hillary Clinton who in
the womb her first Ward when she came
out president Emperor you know and then
you know it's like okay and then no this
guy's like no man I just want to be
around my dad I just want to be around
my family don't forget he is a Kennedy
on the list of democratic names of all
time
you know arguably you get Biden right
down on the bottom you got Obama you got
Clinton
upper echel on top of the list Kennedy
and uh the DNC does not want him making
waves quick question because you brought
up the word voice and you just
interviewed him yeah
it's a very simple question oh he has a
what is the situation with his voice you
can Google it he has an actual medical
condition that's leading to the issue
and and believe it or not I do think you
know sometimes we talk about these sort
of ephemeral issues or the things that
you can't quite put your finger on
whatever the condition that he has I
think we can find it here
um I actually do think that affects a
certain amount of people's ability to
listen to him it's it's an unfortunate
piece but it does people are like asking
what's going on with his voice oh I
guess it's a neurological oh dysphonia I
think it's called Peabody how many times
have you interviewed RFK multiple times
right and you speak them on the phone
so what's your take on the situation
medical condition and that's pretty much
it listen let me let me explain to you
how life works and how weird these
things are okay
I went to an event in November of 2003.
I was in Pasadena Billy Graham is
speaking
and this is the phase where I'm kind of
struggling with you know faith and all
this stuff I'm an atheist but I'm
Christian and I'm kind of like you know
I take this girl who's a Persian she's
with UNICEF and UCLA girl and I'm taking
all these guys we're sitting there this
is how Billy Graham spoke
today
we are here
a hundred thousand of us
at the Old Pasadena Rose bolst and he's
talking like this okay he says I only
have one message for you and one person
says and decide start screaming you're
the Antichrist you're this you're the
devil you're this and everybody gets
upset he says let him say everything he
wants to say for five minutes he doesn't
say anything and he lets this person
rant
and he says all I have to tell you is
God loves you do you know when he was
speaking like that
Adam
the entire you know how it was it was
like this why are you moving oh stop
opening the chips I can't hear the guy
stop dude sit down can you shh we were
all like hundred thousand people at Rose
Bowl I went every single day to watch
him for four days except for one day
because I was doing the training on
Saturday morning and I watched this man
he didn't have energy he walked up in a
walker
and you know you're just listening to
this guy but what you felt 100 was a
man's conviction
dude conviction communicates in ways
that a great motivational speech written
by the greatest motivational speakers
double check by Chad gbt and everybody
else it'll never resonate with people
what RFK has that very few these people
have is conviction and that's what you
and I feel when we watch him speak we
feel the conviction it's very unique and
and there's a reason why it's resonating
his creative momentum so for me as a guy
that's interviewed him and talked to
multiple times and people would say the
stuff about his voice sometimes people
like that they're like more like wow did
he just oh wow oh wow I actually I would
have said this three years ago it's an
issue I don't think it's an issue today
this much so not on the marketing side
but what do you feel so for the things
that you differ with him probably
abortion probably affirmative action oh
guys definitely some economics I don't
want to make it seem like he's my
candidate right right you know I'm not
sitting here telling you that yeah no
not at all I don't agree with them with
affirmative action I don't agree with
them with you know other areas
politically all I'm saying what I
respect about him
you know the old Bernie Sanders I
respect it about Bernie because Bernie
really believed in what he was talking
about when he was going against
anti-establishment until all of a sudden
they scared the crap out of and he
stepped out I don't think you can do to
him what you did to Bernie I don't think
you can do that to him I just don't you
know in life when you go through
when you've lived a hard life
everybody has lived a little bit of a
hard life but some people have really
lived a hard life and there's you know
how they say there's level here I made a
hundred thousand dollars last year great
bro I made a million dollars last year
great you go walk into a room with a
bunch of deca millionaires at a country
club I made 10.2 million out oh my God
that guy walks into a room made 117 oh
my God 170 million dollar guy goes into
a billionaire I'm a billion oh shoot the
billionaire goes into the DECA I'm a 12
Bill the 12 billion goes to Elon Musk
and then Elon Musk goes to Putin or a
couple the oil guys oh [__] I don't have
oil money right but the point is there's
also levels to pain
think about the biggest pains you can
experience in life you know what happens
to a man that has experienced time you
have a man like Teddy Roosevelt you lose
a kid you lose wife you lose the people
you love you lose troops peers best
friends Bro you've been broken so many
[__] times like you just like throw
whatever the hell you want to throw at
me that's where I'm freaking at I'm not
afraid you throw any [__] you want to
throw at me you can't break me
I may be wrong but as a guy that gets
paid to reach people this is my job for
the last 23 years as a person that's
around a sales organ I have to read with
your fellowship whether you're going to
do the work or not that's what I get
paid in the industry I'm a part of
I get a feeling RFK is as real as it
gets and uh you know we have this one uh
misconception about marriage
relationship friendships
candidates that we have to agree with
100 of what this person believes in
uh uh I think that's a naive way of
thinking I think that's an elitist way
of thinking I think that's an arrogant
way of thinking you and I don't agree on
everything in life but dude I love you
yeah I love spending time with you I
actually truly when I see you I
sincerely get happy when I see I'm like
I like this guy right we don't agree on
everything but I like your company like
I have a lot of people around me that's
like that I'm still working on you yeah
no no no we'll get you there don't worry
about that give us a couple years we'll
baptize you trust me yeah just hang
around babe we're pretty good at
persuading people but the point I'm
making here is I don't need to agree
with 100 of what RFK says I don't need
to agree with 100 of what Trump does or
DeSantis does or any of these guys what
I am against is manipulation yeah I
don't feel manipulation with RFK what I
am against is a dark and the
establishment stuff I don't feel that
with him so if you're sincerely wanted
to go at bat with me and we're competing
what you're sincere about it I actually
respect you but if you have dark Vibes
you're not gonna have problems I don't
get that feeling from RFK well I
completely agree with that and I
definitely feel the same way about you
on a personal note but I can tell you by
after doing the hour with him even
though we have those disagreements I
didn't discuss those disagreements with
my team at all it was like those those
things do not matter the heart the the
spirit of what you're talking about
that's the thing that matters with him
that's the Zeitgeist thing that again I
think we're talking about how DeSantis
doesn't have that at least as of yet and
those things are you know you got to
figure out how to deal with those two
things and and you also have to figure
out what again the two questions that I
said at the beginning do you rough in
terms of who you're going to vote for do
you roughly agree with this guy on the
policy stuff and do you think he can do
it that's separate than what you're
talking about on on like the purely
spiritual mission that he's saying RFK
has a secret weapon I don't know if you
know this do you know who his wife is
yeah he's married to Larry David from
Curb your enthusiasm's wife Cheryl Hines
so there's a marketing Guru behind the
scenes pulling some strings yeah I don't
know about that
no I I understand that's his wife but
you know DeSantis has got Casey and but
trust me Casey's a I would put Casey as
number one I don't put anybody ahead of
Casey I'm not when we when I watch Casey
I'm watching I'm like oh my God you have
my vote who are you as a first lady
full-blown qualities communication of
being somebody that I believed her there
was no I'm like I like this girl and she
looks like Jackie Kennedy I didn't find
a picture of her in one of those outfits
that she wears like an inauguration and
then compare that to uh
yeah so her face and we all met I said
you should speak as much as possible by
the way I wasn't speaking about rfk's
wife talking about Larry David
yeah no I get his Corner well you know
you know it's like Larry David in his
corner of course
you know it's Biden's campaign manager
Hunter
is the guy that's behind closed doors is
essentially like the campaign manager
that's doing all this stuff well why
wasn't Biden here we don't think he
needs two right now we think it's too
early we don't think we need to use our
money and our resources
D katzenberg Jeffrey Jeff producer yes
movie producer yes if you can Google
this I think it's the same category is
he produced let me Weekend at Bernie's
he's gonna do the Weekend at Bernie's
just put capsule this time around Biden
just put those together okay put
katzenberg Biden zoom in any of the
stories okay Biden's age yeah this is
the new Power in 2024
yesenberg is the guy the ex-ceo Deep
China wife ties donates 1.7 million
dollars yeah anyways let me say the last
thing about about DeSantis you say It'll
ask him about the Santos I think
oh man
so okay
you know you Mentor different people and
you you see certain things about them
you know your insecurities I know my
insecurities most people
have insecurities some try to hide it
some are very good at permanently hiding
it and then some people are like this is
my insecurity like we know Adam came and
he says hey Charlie you got a big head
he said no I have a big kid I actually
have a very big head right I said your
head looks a lot smaller yeah
here's a question for you here's a
question for you
who do you think in life has made the
least amount of mistakes watch this
question in life who's made the fewest
amount of dumb decisions in his life RFK
Trump Biden DeSantis
Pence who do you think's made the fewest
mistakes yeah that's the problem that's
the problem why is that a problem
what an interesting point you ever met
other than he's much younger dude let me
no no that's not it that's got nothing
to do with it RFK Vivek is super young
it's not it's not because Vivek I think
it's 38 I don't know I think it's 38 or
39. it's got nothing to do with age this
has got to do it who's made the fewest
mistakes is DeSantis do you know nobody
puts more pressure on the census than
himself I don't know the Dynamics of how
he was raised with Mom and Dad we all
like to keep a little bit of it as a
secret you know even in the book Joseph
Kennedy I'm reading Joseph Kennedy
doesn't want to reveal a lot about his
relationship with his mom and dad he
just doesn't want to be because he wants
to identify as I made my own money he
didn't want to give that credit to his
parents
when I watch the scientists I almost
feel like his entire life has been nope
I can't kiss that girl because people
are going to say this nope I can't punch
that guy in the face because they're
going to say this nope I can't do this
because this nope I can't say that
because of no I can't read this because
one day if I ever run and they find out
I wrote this paper my grudge and they're
going to say this I think he's that guy
and I think he needs to have a
one-on-one conversation with himself and
say listen man it's okay to make
mistakes bro all these candidates have
made more mistakes than you America
doesn't relate to Perfect People America
relates to Broken People America relates
to people who have made mistakes America
relates to people that are not perfect
he is too perfect did you happen to see
the video during covid when he actually
broke down crying when he was explaining
that they had locked down those people
and people didn't get to say goodbye to
their parents yes I think that's the
moment that you're looking for you're
looking for that sort of honesty it's
interesting because I'm with you on that
but but to another extent this this also
strikes me sort of like the marketing
thing we're holding something against
the guy like we're sort of saying he's
too functional in a way way and I I and
and that to me strikes me a bit as oh
he's accomplishing too many of the
things we want he's too functional he
does it he doesn't make these crazy
mistakes he doesn't have the sloppy
errors no I know I know that's not
exactly what you're saying but but in
terms of what we're going to vote for
ultimately like we've got a guy that
really has the package I think I agree
with you that there is a vulnerability
that maybe we should see a little bit
more a certain raw passion we should see
a little bit more and that's why I think
that moment that I just referenced was
was a good one I know I I actually I
actually think this is Ron has got to go
away I don't know how many times in my
life you want him to do Ayahuasca no not
Ayahuasca Ron if you're looking for a
foreign
but let me tell you A lot of times I
would say Jen I'll see you at dinner I'm
staying at the Four Seasons I gotta go
think and you would come into my room
and there was all these uh you know
these big papers that you write on but I
like the ones with the tape and the back
we can tip against the wall you would
come into my room and there's like 60 of
them against the wall
here's what I'm going to do with this
part with my Tico I'm going to do this
to raise them this way here's what my
plan is with villain this way here's
what I want to do with this company this
is what I want to do with this part of
my health I don't like my way wait I'm
at 258 can't stand it here's what I'm
going to do my marriage this is what I
want to do with God this is what I want
to do with my finances this is what I'm
going to do my investments and
everything is how to get there right but
the most important part when I did this
exercise and I got away from everybody
including my wife I don't want anything
you can get a hold of me the only person
that can get a hold of me is my wife I'm
in my room trust me call me I'm right
here right phone is off everything's
gone
I would go into sauna and I would sit
there and for two hours I'm in the sauna
jacuzzi all this stuff and I'm just
thinking what do you want to do next
what are you doing this for why do you
need to make the next move why do we
need to go to the next level you versus
upvd nobody exists this has to matter to
you why why why
every time
if I got to the moment where I'm
breaking down by myself I always came
out with better moves
this guy needs to take a break from
everybody
get away for two days it's not a long
time take a Saturday and a Sunday in
Jacksonville
get in a car you can't go to a hotel so
he's got to kind of figure out where to
go to a place that nobody came security
everybody can be outside you need to be
away from everybody and you need to have
a conversation with you
once I'm on a flight back from Chicago I
took a notepad and I wrote down why I'm
afraid of getting married and why I
don't want to get married I have that
paper till today I bring it back I put
in my Samsonite and I'm just writing
well because this happened is because of
this because of that because it is
because of that finally I'm like you
know what I'm good let's roll now you're
going to get perfect but let's roll see
what happens with it okay I had to go
through that moment in a plane I'm like
sitting like this because I don't want
anybody to see me I don't think this is
a let's try to change Ron I don't think
this is a hey run you better say these
17 phrases I don't think this is you
know go give these 19th okay all that
stuff is the how-to I think the Y2 is
why do you give a [__] so much
go back and say you're a good guy you're
doing the right things you ain't perfect
like this whole thing of walking on
Extras around yourself it's got to kind
of stop like go play ball and you may
lose all good or you may win all good
but the way you're going right now what
you're doing I think you're going back
to being so afraid of what are people
going to say if I say this or write this
or do that and it's holding you back
anyways uh we can go to the next I'll
give you the final thoughts here before
we move away from the center no no
listen you're you're talking about
something existential something
ephemeral and and something that
captures that Zeitgeist thing that I
think is right you're you're doing like
a Jordan Peterson move on him that I
think probably would translate into
something that he wants which ultimately
is is to become president right or win
this thing and do it so I I actually
don't disagree with that I don't
disagree that and also it's just a
matter of I think we all have to accept
that you know we might sit here as
relatively functional people and be like
boy I just want the guy who's the best I
don't need all the magic tricks I don't
need all the viralness I don't need all
those things a certain amount of people
do a certain amount of people do whether
we like it or not so if that's a piece
that seems to be missing you're
obviously not the only person saying it
I I actually don't uh I actually do
agree with that fantastic well we're
going to go to the next topic I want to
show a couple of the clips of what
happened with Pence's last day of
running for office
yeah but again guys we're about to
announce at the end of this year the
first town hall we're doing in this
building that'll happen on August 4th
and the tickets are going to sell out
the moment we especially the VIP ones
we're going to meet the candidate and
going to back with the Cigar Lounge and
this person's actually wanting to go to
the Cigar Lounge and meet many of you
text award podcasts to
310-340-1132 once again
310-340-1132 we'll send the link the
moment I announce it at the end of the
podcast so can you play this clip Taco
Carlson okay Tucker Carlson uh uh
conversation that's been coming up with
him on at I asked everybody at Turning
Point USA who went there and I'm asking
different guys to tell me who would the
stars of the best messages they gave
right who are the stars
some say Obviously Trump
then they say Ronald uh uh uh what is
his name gentlemen Byron Byron oh Byron
Daniels no Donald Byron Donald yeah
crushed it right from Southwest forgive
me for not knowing his name is he's a
congressman from Fort Myers
how do you feel about it all the ladies
were waving you kisses he says that's
great but the only one that I'll receive
and kiss back is my wife he's a very
good he's Communicator he's got charm
seen him before I heard Trump yes I
heard Tucker I heard him I heard Kirk
we're the best speakers but a lot of
people said Tucker guns none of the show
as well
what I heard from a lot of people but
before that event at the blaze here's
what happened when he asked a very
friendly question of a uh of a man named
Mike Pence I don't know if you guys have
heard of him he was a former vice
president here's what happened here if
you can play this rap go for it along
the way the Biden Administration has
been slow in providing Military Support
make no mistake about this we promised
him 33 Abrams tanks in January I heard
again two weeks ago in Ukraine they
still don't have them we've been telling
them we'll train their F-16 Pilots but
now they're saying maybe January we'll
let somebody transfer some Jets I'm
sorry Mr vice president have you I know
you're running for president
that the ukrainians don't have enough
American tanks every city in the United
States has become much worse over the
past three years drive around there's
not one city that's gotten better in the
United States
no eye contact yeah the suicide rate has
jumped public filth and disorder and
crime have exponentially increased and
yet your concern is that the ukrainians
a country most people can't find on a
map who've received tens of billions of
U.S tax dollars don't have enough tanks
I think it's a fair question to ask like
where's the concern for the United
States in that well it's not my concern
it's not my concern Tucker I've heard
that routine from you before but that's
not my concern
I'm running for president of the United
States because I think this country is
in a lot of trouble
I mean he comes off as a 1994 Simpsons
Republican right like the caricature at
the at the castle with the lightning
sitting with Mr Burns yeah that's one
thing uh the other thing this idea that
he's like he's upset with Biden because
we promised him 33 Abrams tanks in
January let's say we gave him 66 we
doubled it does anyone think the war
would be going any differently it's just
complete nonsense and then the line
that's not my concern I actually I will
give him a little bit of a leash on that
because I think he just actually because
he's such a robot I I don't think he
meant it that way like I'm not concerned
about America I think he meant I'm not
concerned the way you're framing this
question but Adam you brought up a great
point when Tucker says all the cities in
America are crumbling Miami is not
crumbling plenty of cities in Florida
are not crumbling and there are and
Nashville is not going there are some
cities not every city in America is
doing worse
yeah of course well it does make me
happy seeing that though Dave and and
loving that Americans are just done with
that yeah there's carbon cut out his
hair it's just imagine he's not making
any eye contact he's just looking in the
audience like like he's getting votes
it's like people I think he's what do
you think he's doing because he was is
this just purely to do a little cleanup
job on the association with Trump that
he's like I'll try it so that maybe I'll
be remembered for that you know instead
of the Trump thing like yes do you know
one person that's supporting him one
person that even thinks he should be
running he's he's got half the votes Tim
Scott got on that one poll that we ran
no he's done I think I asked the same
question with Chris Christie like what
is Chris Christie and him doing you're
not going to win so what job are you
trying to get are you trying to get a
job on what Biden Administration or or
is it you know we can go to the dark
side which the dark side is hey uh Mr
Pence who has lived a perfect life These
are three things we know about you that
we found on how you search for Google
and you search on this on that day and
you did this and you did that just want
to let you know you better
respect or else this is going to be
released and when it does your grandkids
are always going to look at daddy as a
perv and they're gonna I don't I'm not
saying this is the truth or not the only
reason a person sounds like this
look at look at the look on his face
right there look at that
person talks like this is because
they're scared and they're trying to
prevent something from happening you
can't suddenly flip like this look
Scottie Pippen writes his book that
flops yeah in the interview they asked
them and they said so how do you want to
remember that do you remember his answer
I don't he says I want to be remembered
as the greatest of all time
did you hear what he said I want to
remember is the greatest of all time by
the way Scottie Pippen is a top 50 of
all time yeah okay top 50. he's not a
greatest of all time Mike Pence is not a
top
1000 or 500 in that space okay he's a
good guy he's a good man he's a good
husband he's done very good with his
family
but he's he can't say I want to be the
president and out to Trump no you're not
that guy so the motive behind it is kind
of funky where he's a role player to
disrupt and kind of mess up somebody
that's ahead of him he's a pawn that's
being used by somebody because aside
from that what are you running for yeah
what are you running for there's nothing
Legacy wise that looks good unless if
you believe that Insurrection I saw a
video the other day that showed the
following it shows the video of you know
the the CNN guy is doing the interview
and he's shown in the back there's fires
yeah mostly about your protests mostly
mostly peaceful peaceful protests
peaceful men and women out here they're
just upset and you see January 6 they're
standing in front this is an
Insurrection this is these guys this
yeah okay flamboyant you're selling all
this stuff and Pence kind of weird for
me Chris Christie I can understand it
because Chris Christie I actually
understand Chris Christie more than I
understand Pence Chris Christie is kind
of trying to protect his legacy to go
and say
that was a good recommendation with
Chris Ray I actually think Chris Ray's
done a good job so he's defending the
recommendations he made and Chris
Christie
you know probably as envious I think
Chris Christie's more the envious guy
you know uh my concern with him and I
think he's a topic I'd love to have him
on the podcast but it's very hard if if
you want to control the national debt
that's ballooned but you have a hard
time controlling your own national debt
in your body you know you got to first
cut off some of that debt there's a
legit Optical issue there yeah so so for
me Optical I actually understand Chris
Christie's fight I don't understand
Pence's fight at all and by the way
watch what he did with Asa you want to
play the clip with Asa asa's question
with covet was like game over in 15
seconds this thing didn't last that long
this is a 20 seconds he has that haircut
too watch this
the powers that government did usurp uh
over the past several years is is the
right to decide what medicine you take
in the form of of covet mandates
um how did you feel about that and how
many coveted shots did you take and how
do you feel about it now
in retrospect how many covered shots did
you take zero
zero
just no hesitation like he's not really
running it's a complete far so I don't
think we have to waste two brain cells
on ASA Hutchinson there's an interesting
thing here with Tucker though because
you know asking someone their personal
medical history is a bit of a slimy move
I like Tucker as much as you do uh I was
on air at the height of covid on Fox
latv with Gloria Allred you know Gloria
Allred famous civil rights attorney and
she asked me on air on live TV if I had
been vaccinated and I said when was the
last time you got laid because those
questions because those questions were
that was a great question valid yeah
that's that's the moment right there
yeah you have to play This Way watch
this here
yes children could transmit the disease
although they rarely do but the parents
are all vaccinated if they're good
decent citizens so I don't really
understand the connection actually are
you a good decent citizen are you
vaccinated
it's nobody's business whether I'm
vaccinated that's like me asking you the
last time you got laid I mean it's just
all right so you know what's really
really beautiful that it's one thing if
you have the right to choose
your business nor yours is mine
you know what's so crazy about that clip
that woman is a civil rights attorney
she's a legendary civil rights attorney
the idea that she would go on a
television show and ask somebody their
medical history is so insane and then
and then actually try to coerce me and
the viewers into doing something that
turned out to be complete nonsense by
the way when I was saying good and
decent citizen I was obviously being
sarcastic uh but the point is that
Tucker asking him that was was I think
there's something to think about there
if we want to really go down that road
and I'm I'm not vaxxed and is what it is
um but the other thing is you know
Tucker never said it until then which I
thought was interesting because he was
on Fox for you know basically two years
post mandates and all that nonsense and
it would have been interesting had he
said it when he was there or said I
can't get into the building because I'm
not vaccine I'm actually that's not a
judgment call on Tucker I think you know
everyone has their own calculations but
he he obviously was waiting for this
moment so let me ask this question here
let me ask this question here so what is
what is a uh what's Tucker's fight okay
so uh uh uh there's a there's a few ways
to look at this right on what Tucker
wants to do and everybody gives a
different answer I think he's trying to
do this his channel he's definitely not
doing this he's definitely not doing
that et cetera et cetera okay so a lot
of guys like if you think about the
lineage of what makes for a great
president is it former military is that
what makes for a great president or
those days are 40 years behind us it's
no longer about the military is it a
great uh um media person who is a you
know a celebrity like a Arnold or a
trump like is that what it is it is is
it a journalist like a writer you know a
Churchill or Netanyahu somebody that's
kind of been in that space where you
kind of know every story that's been
going on for 10 20 30 years businessman
a businessman is another one because
media could be different than a
businessman like Arnold is a business
Jamie dimon you know Trump guys like
that what is the best one so so Tucker
is Tucker a
great king
is he a king maker is he a talent is he
a person that is helping out a candidate
today because in 2028 he's gonna all of
a sudden announce that he's running and
he's going to become a two-term
president does he want to go out there
and be a media Mogul billionaire Rupert
Murdoch does he want to be a Roger L's
King maker does he want to be a Rush
Limbaugh replace all of that times 10.
what do you think Tucker's next place
what's your uh what's your policy on the
F-bomb on the podcast no no you're good
because I'll tell you I'll give you an
exact quote from Tucker the first time
Tucker came to my house was in my studio
when I lived in Sherman Oaks in LA and I
had my studio in my garage and it was
very early on of anyone actually being
independent building their own studio
all of the stuff that you've now done he
walks into my house opens the door to
the garage I'm sitting on set already
opens the door and this is exactly what
he said he said holy [__] [__] you
did it man meaning I had built a
television in quality broadcast quality
studio in my garage it blew his mind he
then wrote In the book he wrote he wrote
you're doing it for all the suckers like
me who are getting a paycheck for
someone else wow so I'll tell you this I
think there's two two things there on
the micro level on the micro level his
his most his biggest desire right now is
I think to build some sort of network be
the the new independent voice really do
what we are doing really I think he sees
that as the future I think he's now
incredibly angry at Fox obviously I know
he's not he seems very appeased
personally but I mean there's a there's
going to be a Vengeance level there he
wants to build New Media and then there
may be a political play beyond that I
actually don't really sense that from
him I think he senses probably like you
sense when people say to you why don't
you run for president or when they say
to me why don't you run for governor
it's like I think there's a way we can
affect things in a bigger way from the
outside and still maintain our dignity
and and our good Lifestyles and all
those things I think he's really into
that I think he's happy driving his
little golf cart around his little
island and Florida and all of those
things so I don't see the political part
but I do see the media Empire part and
to really he loves ideas to shape what
the discourse especially on the right
will be culturally I think I think
that's his thing well I mean the story
came out the fact that uh what store
what page is that on rob the story came
out about him raising money there it is
uh uh Reuters Tucker Carlson to create a
new media company uh Wall Street Journal
reports uh this is on page 12 uh and I
think they're raising 100 million
dollars uh uh former Fox News host stuck
across in a former White House advisor
Neil Patel are looking to raise funds to
start a new media company that could
potentially be anchored on Twitter The
Wall Street Journal report on Friday the
duo is looking to raise hundreds of
millions of dollars to fund the company
the report's exciting people familiar
with the matter the company would be
anchored by longer versions of the free
videos that Carlson has been posting
regularly on Elon musk's Twitter since
his departure from Fox News but would
ultimately be driven by subscription
according to the report Carlson and Fox
News three to part ways in April after
the whole 787 million dollar million
dollar lawsuit with the Dominion voting
system by airing false allegation
rigging claims Etc et cetera so and then
at the same time Insider comes out with
a story
talking about the number of views we're
talking Carlson's new show on Twitter
has dropped by 86 since its launch okay
uh Tucker Carlson's new show on Twitter
uh has experienced a staggering 86
percent of the decline in video since
its launch in June the latest episode
garnered 3.8 million views compared to
the impressive 26 million views on the
first episode they're dropping Carlson's
viewership on Twitter coincides with the
overall decline of the platform Twitter
advertising sales plummeted by 59
recently partly attributed to an
increase in hate speech additionally
Twitter Space Twitter faces uh
competition from metas threats which
gained over 30 million downloads in its
first day and received a cease and
desist letter from Elon musk's attorney
allegian employee poaching and copying
so two questions one there's a lot of
nonsense
react to all of it on one them raising
money with Neil Patel and two what
insiders saying about his viewership
dropping well let's do the viewership
thing first one thing you didn't mention
there that it says in the article is
that Twitter right now counts of you you
as two seconds of view time you would
never for your podcast count that as a
viewer and they change it in May by the
way to be fair so there's some question
as to what Twitter is doing on the
numbers side because the numbers don't
quite make sense when he gets 50 million
views it's like well does that mean
someone just literally scrolled past it
on their phone happened to pick up a
drink at that moment so their phone
stopped and now that counts as a view so
there is some legitimate questions in
terms of what's actually a view and how
much how much that's actually worth you
know even if you if you do an hour-long
show and someone only watches a minute
did they even see an ad is there you
know is there a way to sell that all of
those things uh this concept that
there's somehow more hate speech on
Twitter is sort of absurd because as the
Supreme Court has decided there's no
such thing as hate speech and actually
Twitter is a lot Freer now so if you
want to be in a curated silenced Silo
you should go to threads but also you
guys probably saw threads usage is down
by about a quarter in a week and
Zuckerberg hasn't even posted on the
freaking thing in a week so there's a
there's a lot of stuff there but yes on
the on the media side I think he would
love to build what we've built on
steroids I think that's the direction
how successful you think he's going to
be how big you think it'll be he'll have
unbelievable access to money he'll have
unbelievable access to talent I think he
has the cultural Zeitgeist he gets
what's going on on the right
um he also seems in a really good place
sort of mentally and spiritually and
philosophically so I think there's I
think there's kind of endless upside
there Rob I'm text by the way I'm not
insulting You by looking at my phone I'm
just trying to get this one because my
phone iPad all of a sudden started
updating I'm trying to send you these
two pictures to show on threats because
he did say something about threads that
people need to see uh Rob I just send it
to you here here's a couple things I'll
say about the whole numbers dropping off
Etc et cetera well first of all he
hadn't spoken for a couple months
whatever the timeline was then his first
video came up of course the first video
is going to be right an unfair
expectation that every episode's gonna
do what the first one's gonna do that's
not how stuff works out you know you
have to be very realistic about that
first one is going to be four to five
times bigger than anything else you're
doing it goes back to the normal numbers
that people do I'm willing to bet out of
people who watch the first episode uh if
I were to ask a thousand Tucker fans if
you watch the first episode and how many
have you watched all the episodes after
that I'm willing to bet 90 is going to
say I watched the first one but I
probably only seen one or two other
after the next one that's natural that's
normal that's gonna happen but
you know it's it's great when people
want to go after a guy they fear as much
that's what's going on with Tucker being
you know it rogans the goat and the
podcasting space Tucker is the goat in
the mainstream you know whatever you
want to call it's a different kind of a
model of a business but he's also proven
that I don't you know he can do the
model of fox he can also do this and
even his style of the show you know he's
reading and he wrote it himself when
he's going to you know people may be
helping him out but it's him saying that
him writing it but when you also see him
when he gave a speech you know and he's
very animated and he's like loose and
he's like you almost feel like he you
know it's like I feel like the handcuffs
and shackles are off of you know what he
can and can't say and he's letting it
rip doing what he's doing but uh it's
going to be exciting to see what this
guy's going to be doing Rob I don't know
if you have the two different data I
want you to see this you know what's
happened to them this is threads versus
Twitter there was a day where everybody
was like oh my God I love threads I
can't stand Twitter I'm off I'm gonna go
black as threads so take a look at this
boom threats is ahead of Twitter for how
long half a second and then all of a
sudden where does it go boom it's
trending in a bad way and it's forgotten
I go to the next one I send you two of
them and this is the other one as well
look what's happened there it's pretty
much I've sent two things on threads
just to see what it'll look like and how
it's done and then it's going back to
Twitter by the way there's a couple
things here with threads because you
know threads first off if you were to do
a Google search on the the mainstream
media hits if you just check threads
right like they are loving threads right
they want everyone to know that the
celebrities are moving their threads
blown up it's all great if you just do a
news search it's all going to be good
there might be one or two things about
now how Zuck is using a little bit less
uh but everything will basically be
positive then if you do a Google News
search on Twitter it's all negative it's
always Elon did this hate speech this
blah blah blah so all that but the the
bigger idea with threads is that what in
the world would you have have to be
thinking to go to a to follow Mark
Zuckerberg the guy who admitted that he
was working with the government to
censor people during covet he's now
saying to everybody hey I am creating a
censorship style Twitter please follow
me to that and and apparently a hundred
million people followed him and then
very quickly got bored of it but the
very concept that you would that you
would build a new tech company a new
product an app based in censorship and
that a crazy amount of people actually
want to follow you to that world I mean
that's a very reverse Matrix red pill
situation stolen out blue pills and
people are going yes I'd like another
I'll give a real life example that's
just basically reaffirming what you guys
are saying so
I used to win The Nightlife business so
you can substitute restaurant for it or
pretty much anything
the the blue line is the your your Venue
your established nightlife Club your
restaurant whatever oh there's a new
restaurant down the block they're gonna
open up they're gonna kick your ass
opening night there's a line out the
Block it's like what we would say in
Nightlife is talk to me in a year is the
club still even gonna be there because
it's all about sustainability and look
opening night they killed it everyone's
talking about threads
a week later nobody's talking about
threads now talk to me in a year so
let's see if that club's still open it's
not easy this game is not easy I mean
listen threats is the new Google Plus is
what it is the the number one website
you and I go to to search things is
Google and they try to create a social
media company and when's the last time
you thought about Google Plus actually
when is the last time you logged on to
go to Google Plus does it even
exists anymore active users are there on
Google Plus actually there it is they
start to shut it down in 2019. Imagine
the number one searched website in the
world launches a social media company
based on the search website google.com
and they failed and now Facebook is
doing right can I can I tell you and
also look at CNN plus they're doing well
it was amazing she crushed it on that
one interview I don't know if you
remember that or not oh you're talking
about when she went with the reporter
and she's like
you'll love this Pat so you know when I
created locals.com really what I was
creating it was before we it wasn't even
called locals all I was trying to do was
I wanted to build a subscription Network
for myself the ability just basically to
take what patreon does and replicate it
so I own it so I could never be kicked
off it and build that for my business we
we built that for me first and then
after about two months realizing wow
we're making money this thing's working
I was like wait a minute wait a minute
if this thing works for me there's a
million creators like me out there why
don't we see if we can expand on this
then we started the company we obviously
got some investment built out the
company and all those things but I think
what we did first that worked that
threads did not do and all of these apps
don't do is we had we had a problem that
needed to be solved and we went to saw
of that problem you don't want to be
reliant on big Tech you want to be an
independent Creator here are the tools
to go ahead and do that and that's what
we built and that's why we merged with
Rumble and that that whole story threads
was not trying to solve a problem no
because they're the what their their
perceived problem was that there is too
much free speech but that's not a real
problem so everyone going to threads was
in essence trying to solve a problem
that doesn't exist you know what I mean
so when he says
on day one when they launched the thing
uh Zuckerberg put up a tweet he said
well we want this place to be fun yeah
and it's like well that's not really
what the problem is that people are
having fun online I think of Mark
Zuckerberg I think
yeah he's the man but but he also meant
right under fun was censored right
because the only way you keep this thing
fun and light and happy and everyone's
smiling you're gonna have to censor the
[__] out of an awful lot of people so he
solved a problem that did not exist and
I think people start intuitively
realizing that over a couple weeks and
that leads to where we're at and by the
way I will say this he may not look like
he's a fun guy trust me Zuckerberg is
having a lot of fun whether it's Jiu
Jitsu whether it's water skiing the
stuff that he's doing is crazy how
active he is out there so yeah he's an
aliens boring on the outside that's
amazing 100 billion dollars will do to
uh enable you to happen believe it or
not no no there's a lot of billionaires
who will never do [__] like this and
they just want to count their
endorsing this I'm just saying this guy
looks like he's having a fun life but
you know it's funny you say that how
many of your DMs on Instagram do you
respond to
me personally almost nothing but that
guy right there handles it Phoenix does
okay Brock Brock yeah oh okay how many
of your Twitter messages do you respond
is it also somebody else virtually not
do you respond to any one of them I
respond to things on locals your
response to things because I built it so
that if you really want to contact me
and you want to start a conversation
with me yeah you gotta I gotta you gotta
Pony so what we did is we launched an
app called minute yeah yeah so connect
where you know last month we got 60 000
downloads of the app which was very
interesting to see what's happening you
know we've paid influencers anywhere
between five thousand dollars in a month
200 000 just last month in the month of
June I think one person got paid ninety
three thousand dollars people who are
answering the questions but that'll
respond so you have three options on
minute if you if you look up minette.com
you can you know people DM you all the
time you're like dude I don't want to
respond back I can either respond back
in texting you choose your price point
yep 10 bucks 50 bucks 100 bucks 500
bucks and then you get to respond back
in text or if you want a video you can
send a video back or you can can have a
15 minute Face Time call with the person
or an hour FaceTime call I think Adam
had a day a couple days ago he did you
know calls with people and making three
thousand dollars four thousand dollars
in a day just doing the next I think
there's a part there to monetize the
influencers and by the way quick plug if
you're not using my neck download the
app you have a bunch of different people
ask questions if you're a expert
yourself it's also a good place for you
to be on and share with your Audience by
the way it also changes the behavior of
the internet you know because of
anonymity and because of burner accounts
and everything it encourages the worst
behavior possible you ask people you
know my my community we leave it up to
everybody's locals Community you decide
your price point so mine is five dollars
a month I think Scott Adams is seven we
have people that have 15 whatever it is
but quite literally if you did 25 cents
per month you can completely alter
everybody's Behavior because once they
just put in something you might even be
able to do it at a penny I kid you not
once they have to do something that's
such a good you have completely altered
their behavior and it's not that I'm
looking to alter behavior in terms of
how people think or anything else but if
you're going to be part of my time and
my expenses mentally and otherwise then
yeah shout out to the manic team by the
way
it didn't I mean what a great app that
we got going on over there yeah and it's
we we uh got the team to be thicker
right now we got a lot of people it's
exciting what about we're about to
launch next but I want to I want to give
you guys this one article here very
important for all of us to be prepared
for this and and before I go with Ron
Perlman losing his mind against an
executive that made 27 million dollars
in a year and what microaggression is 15
things people think are fine to say at
work but are actually racist sexist and
offensive according to Insider Rob we
have some breaking news on what happened
this morning on Truth social with Trump
what he tweeted out 30 minutes ago if
you want to show this Trump says he's he
expects arrest and indictment over
January 6 Capital right this just came
out this morning uh president Donald
Trump said Tuesday that he expects to
get indicted on federal charges on
January 6 Capital right support is
disrupted certification of the 2020
election he's a front-runner election
interference wow on Sunday night while I
was with my family having just arrived
with Turning Point event in Florida
where I was the straw straw poll against
all the other Republican candidates with
85.7 percent with all polls showing me
leading in the Republican primary
by very substantial numbers almost
everyone predicting that I will be
Republican nominee for president and as
I am leading Democrat Joe Biden in the
polls by a lot horrifying news for our
country was given to me by my attorneys
deranged Jack Smith the prosecutor with
Joe Biden's doj sent a letter again it
was on Sunday night stating that I am I
am a target of the January 6th grand
jury investigation and given giving me a
very short four days to report to the
grand jury which almost always means an
arrest and indictment go a little Lord
to see if there's anything else Trump
added so now Joe Biden's attorney
general Merrick Garland who I turned
down for the United States Supreme Court
in retrospect based on this corrupt and
unethical actions A very wise decision
together with Joe Biden's Department of
Injustice have effectively issued a
third indictment and the rest of Joe
Biden's number one political opponent
who is largely dominating him in the
race for the presidency nothing like
this has ever happened in our country
before or even close
uh and obviously on the bottom it says
he's been arrested all right so what are
your thoughts on this
well first off the way he writes it
really you should be studied and I don't
know what they should do with it
um well what are they saying they're
arresting him for for inciting a riot I
mean what's the he's not saying what the
actual charge is a target of the January
is there anything else on the bottom ROP
if you want to go a little lower to see
if there's anything else because you
must have something to do with inciting
it right yeah that might be the yeah his
attitude that day he was actually the
shaman he dressed yeah
it really makes you wonder if they had
not done this New York charge if this
federal case had not happened which
happened to be on Miami it has nothing
to do with Florida
um and and now another one of these it
really makes you wonder where Trump
would be at in the polls because this
scene it it's almost as if the system is
keeping him inflated by continually
doing these things it keeps everybody
defending him all the time we'd know we
need to know a little bit more about the
specific you're saying inflated yeah
because it's actually a good thing I
think well we know he gets a bump every
single time more people feel that they
have to defend it right so he's leaning
into it it shows people yeah so of
course he's leaning into it here uh I
don't think the guy wants to end up in
jail again we need to know about the
specifics it must be about inciting a
riot which they're gonna have a real
hard time proving because you know
there's plenty of video of him that day
go peacefully here you know and now we
know we also know about all the Feds
that were in the crowd and moving
barriers out of the way and so this is
just oh man The Show Must Go On we all
agree The Show Must Go On version no
matter what
Trump's not literally ending up in jail
that's not happening no I don't think so
there there's things
because he could be in jail and still
run for the like he could still be
locked up which would be hilarious
that'd be like the real the Orange is
the New blade
but Dave you made a good point
that's just hilarious you heard it here
first but like you would think Dave
because there's obviously left the
left's tactic you'd think that they
would get it like just leave him the
hell alone all you're doing is helping
him look I mean the conspiracy version
of that would be that they want
everybody to be into Trump because they
want him to be the nominee because he
will not win and that he is far more
again putting aside everything that that
uh we discussed about DeSantis that
DeSantis is from where I sit clearly
more of a mainstream threat to take out
uh Biden in an actual General you can
get crossover votes you can see it Trump
if we're to believe the last election
was true right and Biden got 81 million
votes and Trump got 70 but there are no
new Trump supporters there just are
there aren't I don't think there are new
Biden supporters either but and again
you can question whether the election
was legitimate and all of that stuff but
it seems fairly obvious to me the system
itself would love Trump to run because
Trump will not be president where the
system actually doesn't know exactly how
to react whether it was DeSantis or any
even if it was Nikki Haley someone that
was functional that could cross appeal
people are pissed at the Democrats so
there's some level of that maybe that's
going on here they just want to keep
inflating him fully agree with you I
think that there's a there's a
faction of the DNC that says we did it
once we can do it again Trump's approval
ratings if you trust 538 yeah are just
as low as Biden's give or take a point
or two
and the age thing won't be an issue and
what do you think about that the idea
that that the machine and Essence wants
to keep Trump afloat because they want
him as the nominee
about things differently I know that I I
okay so because what because the santasy
can beat them yeah because they're
because there's every reason why you
want to go there I'm going to go put
aside to Santa this but that the idea
that forget the Santas or any of the
others that they want to keep Trump in
the mix because it puts a sort of stain
on the Republicans and I talk to guys
behind closed doors who are pro de
santis or pro-trump or anti-desantis or
anti-trump or just I like the scientist
but I'm going to vote for a republican
no matter who it is like you saw Brian
Kemp you know Kemp was asked a question
by the girl from CNN or MSNBC was like
so are you going to be supporting uh
president Donald Trump if he's the
nominee serious I absolutely will be
supporting him he says but you were the
same one that wasn't agreeing to you
know help him out says yeah that's
something that I'm not going to do I'm
not going to come but I'm there's no way
in the world the alternative is Joe
Biden I'm not going to have Joe Biden
win it so of course I'm going to go
support Trump that's kind of good to see
Kemp doing that I think he's set in the
tone for everybody else sure but there's
a few different arguments out there one
of them is
what does DeSantis know something the
rest of us don't know that's one
argument which is what
is the establishment behind closed doors
saying don't worry Trump's not going to
be there at the end it's going to be you
and you'll be the front runner running
against these guys because there's a
market of people that descend between
the two who's more establishment the
center is a more establishment that's
what the argument is than Trump right
yeah I don't necessarily agree with that
argument no you don't have to agree with
that I'm just saying like in a market a
lot of people will say between the two
if we have to choose who's more
establishment it's DeSantis not at the
level of Mike Pence okay not at the
level of you know maybe even Chris
Christie
but it's more establishment than Trump
is because he's come through the system
military Congress Governor he's been in
it more than Trump has right Trump was
asked a question by Mario bartiroma on
you know how do you feel about the fact
that people are saying you actually
didn't drain the swamp you know the
sentence keeps saying you're saying you
were going to drain the swamp you didn't
drain the swamp the wall is only 50
miles and all this other stuff that's a
great argument the scientists make but
what are Trump said Trump's response was
uh he said uh it's brilliant by the
water's response was he said yeah you're
right but guess what I've been spending
time networking in New York those guys I
know who the swamp is in New York I
don't know who the swamp is in DC I just
showed up to and he says first of all
when me and the first lady walked up and
we found out we won we're like oh [__]
we want what are we going to do now he
says it took me four years to realize
who was swamp I realized Chris Christie
is swamp I made a wrong decision hiring
Bill Barr hiring esper hiring some of
these guys yeah and that's what he was
saying so Christopher to me he is now
coming from that side but for them to
say you know this is going to help them
or this is not going to help him and
Santa's going to come in if DeSantis is
using that as a play I think you're
playing defense you're not playing
offense but now let's say the other side
that they're doing this because they
don't want the scientists to uh uh be
the nominee if that's the case why are
all these liberal media Outlets saying
the following this is what the liberal
media Outlets are saying the the
following they're saying
uh you know DeSantis ramazwani and Haley
got Wall Street donations over Trump
okay or Trump nominating
Ray was a mistake Chris Christie
recommends why is everybody
who is wanting this defending and
trashing it's even the liberal side is
not playing consistent with them wanting
a trump over DeSantis because if they're
thinking like this is helping out I
think if you don't fear Trump as a
candidate get out of his way
if you don't fear trumpet you're like oh
we want Trump as a candidate you do yeah
don't do this
leave it alone because now the whole
Witch Hunt thing is now on steroids
what's the next thing and what's the
next thing and what's the next thing
guess what while they're doing this the
two numbers that are the most consistent
numbers right now if you look at the
trust America has in mainstream media
and to trust America as in the US
government it's the lowest it's ever
been yeah ever the American people left
or right do not trust mainstream media
and they do not trust the government so
the organization we don't trust keeps
saying Trump this Trump that they're
like dude I don't believe anything these
guys are saying right now I don't
believe anything so I think it's like
the whole concept of you know they want
to be able to do this because they
they're uh wanting uh Trump as a descent
as a candidate versus DeSantis I think
that's the DeSantis Camp liking to hear
that there's this whole concept of
selective hearing that we want to hear
certain things because it validates you
know the whole what do they call it the
bias there's a there's a name
cognitive bias like you only see the
stuff that you want to see because it
agrees with what you're thinking that
leaves blind spots and I don't think
that's true you know it's interesting
this concept that somehow DeSantis is
more in the machine or more part of the
swamp or something it's like DeSantis
has done literally everything any of us
could have asked to fight the machine
getting ESG out of all the Florida
institutions that's basically as big as
it can get fighting the woke at every
freaking level the gender stuff in
Florida the race stuff in Florida he has
done all of the things that any of us
could have asked and yet still and this
is one of the one of my frustrations
with Trump again who I voted for has
been his level of lying on DeSantis I
think has convinced a lot of people
things about DeSantis that simply are
not true DeSantis has said he has met
Paul Ryan once in his entire life Donald
Trump has spent an awful lot of time
around Paul Ryan you can watch the
compilation videos of him saying all
tons of good things about Paul Ryan over
the years Donald Trump worked with Karl
Rove I think I think DeSantis said he he
also has met him once before he was
president you can and you can check me
on that
um so we have a guy who you can say okay
he's not rich so he'll be beholden to
the Richer something like that and I
think all of those arguments can be made
but if you just look at the proof is in
the pudding who has done all of the
things that they said they were going to
do and they're all the things that are
to fight the swamp and fight the machine
the answer obviously is DeSantis while
Trump Rich billionaire okay has in many
ways been defeated by the by that very
swamp so I think I think you can
probably argue that both ways yeah
that's a that's a good point uh but for
me if we have to say like on the Trump
side here's Trump Style
uh Trump style is
um
flattery is one of his weapons he knows
how to control you through flattering
it's also a weakness by the way let's
not let's not forget that during covid
he well now he admitted it postcoded
where he said you know I could never hit
Gavin Newsom too hard because he always
said nice things about me right so his
this flattery thing works Kim Jong-un I
love him he says nice things about me
right I don't understand I'm just
telling you what I think he does I think
he does flattery I think he is charm I
think he is charismatic but I also think
if he gets one inkling that you're not
on his side he flips on you so hardcore
that he wants to destroy you this is
mindset by the way like it or don't like
it that's what he's done he's from New
York okay he comes from a different
lineage of he was a real estate guy he
had to ask the question so what do you
think about Baron what could you tell
him I like him a lot he's strong he's
this and he's vicious I like the fact
that my son is vicious he compliments
Baron using the word vicious like you
have to know this guy really if he's
your father he's feeding you stuff like
this to you Adam the world's an ugly
place don't trust a lot of people
everybody wants to take advantage of you
there's only a few people that's the
stuff that I think he feeds his kids and
by the way these are not bad things to
feed your kids it's work for him and no
when you get to a level like that you
learn you've been screwed by Girls by
Men by peers by Friends by business
partner politicians you know what you
shouldn't trust a lot of people because
of what really is taking place here and
he needs to give his son a speech like
that because you walk around the world I
think it sounds like something his son
is ridiculous getting me noticeable and
your last name is Trump yeah you're
going to be getting it from all sides
but by the way when you take the end
endless BS from the machine all the time
the media and the politicians everything
it hardens you over time I think we
talked about this once have you ever
seen any of those old videos of trump on
Oprah or Trump on film yeah from the mid
early 80s they're incredible you listen
to this guy he's saying in essence the
same exact things but his affect is very
different because he's much softer back
then he's there's a there's a
pleasantness and a calmness where now
it's Gruff and it's angry because he's
been through 40 Years of insanity so but
but yeah you can watch anything and
David I do agree though the anger the
the Vendetta though because let's let's
not forget all the Trump voters that I
know that are going back for him they're
pissed off because he came in they were
colluding with Hillary the FBI cheating
call the media you know fake news FBI is
off all full of [__] the Deep State he
has a vendetta where he's like listen I
came in I won fan square look at the
shitstorm I cause where everybody
everybody even in his own cabinet or
against him to get him out it's it's
payback time and I could see why some of
the anger would come out just like uh
RFK bro the government killed your
father and your uncle guess what that's
where you have that attitude that's why
he's anti-war that's why he's you know
Pro you know you know like you know RFK
was killed for what didn't want to go to
get everybody out of Vietnam he wanted
to splint to the CIA into a into a
million pieces he wanted to you know end
segregation and stuff like that so they
had to kill him so I could see why Trump
is so angry now because bro if I can if
you came into a competition all of us
Dave and you came in and before you even
got in Hillary was doing what she was
doing with the FBI with the fake dossier
with everything the media is all you
know lying to you and then all you have
to do is you say fake news and that woke
up everybody to how much full of [__]
they are I'd be I'd be furious too by
the way here here's the part to realize
on the anger side okay
uh are voters angry today absolutely
hell yeah is America angry today yeah
absolutely so guess who relates to that
the voters yes those who are angry is
like wait a minute did you force me to
take the vaccine I had a couple friends
here from Ecuador a couple days ago
they're at the house and we're talking
and he's talking about how bad it is
right now in Ecuador with Korea Korea is
like almost about to come back and the
current president that's there he's
gonna probably lose it because
election's coming up and Korea is like
this ridiculous Power Trip type of guy
who's wanting to take the philosophy of
what Castro and some of these other guys
did and I'm sitting there saying you
know we didn't take the vaccine
and him and his wife look at us like
we're aliens he said what do you mean he
says Jennifer and I wouldn't take a
single vaccine not a vaccine not a boost
or nothing says nothing zero I said but
my dad took it because he chose to take
it we didn't judge him my nanny took it
because she chose it no we didn't judge
him says you guys didn't take the
vaccess at zero says Patrick we couldn't
go to the store we couldn't go buy
anything everywhere in Ecuador you went
out you had to show your vaccine card or
else you can go to a restaurant you can
go to the store you know those people on
what happened to them in New York the
restaurants that you put out of business
do you know what happens with a
restaurant that's been there for three
generations and my restaurant that my
great grandfather started you caused it
to go out of business you're not like
well I'm a little bit upset but let's
move on guys no you're angry yes you're
angry so Trump is connecting with that
angry so I completely agree with that
but then if you think about it a step
later uh or just one layer deeper you
know Trump also pushed warp speed Trump
gave fauci an award on his last day in
office gave him an honorable whatever
you call it so Trump made mistake that's
one of the things that's interesting
about the Trump base they're the most
radically anti-vaxx and certainly
anti-mandate and he was never for a
mandate so I'll give credit where
creditors do yeah but he also he was
swallowed by the swamp in that regard
how many videos have you seen of fauci
saying we would meet with Trump and he
would say do whatever you want to do the
drain the swamp guy actually handed the
keys to the castle to the swamp it's
interesting how the base does not seem
to associate those two things you know
guys I really want to go to this last
story here with the microaggression I
know we got three minutes left I'm going
to just read a couple of them because
it's that funny
that funny okay so it's page 16 at the
bottom what this is inside a Rob if he
can pull up the story so the audience
can see the story as well to see how
ridiculous the stuff they're writing
right now what is micro aggression 15
things 15 things people think they are
fine to say at work but are actually
racist sexist or offensive guys oh my
God ready you're so articulate
complimenting a person of color under
articulation perpetuates racial
stereotypes and implies low expectations
you're so OCD on how you manage projects
or damn you work on so many different
things like you have ADHD joking about
mental health conditions reinforces
stigma can be damaging okay
you're transgender wow you don't look
like it at all okay you're transgender
you don't look like it at all commenting
on a transgendered person's appearance
reinforces negative stereotypes and
undermines their identity oh sorry wrong
person mistaken names based on race or
ethnicity reinforces the notion that all
individuals of a particular group look
the same oh you're gay you should meet
my friend Anne she's gay too assuming
compatibility amongst lgbtq individuals
disregards individual preferences and
reinforces stereotypes but lesbians do
all sleep with each other everyone knows
that come on you meet a lesbian she has
slept with every other lesbian that's
out there
my boss is crazy using gender terms like
crazy or hysterical to describe female
bosses undermines their concerns and
critical thinking by the way this keeps
going where are you actually from the
way you've overcome your disability is
so inspiring praising disabled
individuals for basically
accomplishments perpetuates low
expectations and undermines their
capabilities your name is so hard to
pronounce I think you're in the wrong
room this is the programmer's meeting do
you even know what Snapchat is are you
an intern you look so young is that your
real hair well actually I think
interrupting women and taking credit for
their idea undermines the contributions
and reinforces gender disparities why do
you wear that probing religious
individuals do you realize how insane of
a word so wait sorry what was the one
about you're in the wrong room you might
be in the room
to the wrong room has broken 12 out of
the 15 today 12 of those just in the
past two three hours but you know can
you imagine working at Insider hey I got
a message for those of you guys that
actually work for Business Insider I
have sympathy for you you don't have to
walk on eggshells there is a land
outside of Insider that is a free land
it's a place where you can actually have
fun and be free with others and have
your own thoughts and think for yourself
so for some of you that hate working at
your job where you have to think like
this and walk on eggshells you may want
to start posting your resume and looking
for elsewhere and I'm not saying come
work at valuetainment because you may
not like how crazy we are but there's
definitely better place number six crazy
my boss is crazy huh Adam I take that as
a compliment Philly pbd before we rap I
just want to say you're a beautiful
transgender woman
[Laughter]
and he's my crazy boss and and I'm so
offended you know that I am so offended
by the way Peabody the way that you've
overcome your disability is so inspiring
unbelievable
it's taken years but uh for me my ESL
has helped me back I never took English
101 but where are you actually from
Europe yes
what's the other one Amid Amid is the
other one you like to teach me with
they're still teaching his English words
yeah I'm getting better
Amid Amid the current situation you're
supposed to say yours years I can't say
that I said yours it's like ears
they let you on the internet that's why
I don't know why they're like this guy
can't even say is that your real hair
yeah yeah so so look I asked my kids the
other said guys am I old daddy not yet
not yet you're still young you're not
young but you're not old yet so that's
the compliment that matters the most
anyways uh Dave as usual pleasure having
you on every time we just love the
conversation two hours goes by in five
minutes I want to tell you guys who
we're going to have at our town hall uh
and by the way we didn't even ask about
talk about this guy that's going to be
out of town so funny we had 100 topics
we didn't even get into a little bit we
saw some numbers that people wanted to
see him so the town hall yeah absolutely
people have been asking about this for a
minute August 4th in Florida in Fort
Lauderdale Vivek ramaswani will be right
here doing a town hall with us with 200
people in attendance there's going to be
three tiers of tickets General uh and
then you have what's the top on Go
premium and mvip the VIP folks will get
a chance to sit in the front row will
come to you possibly to ask some
questions when you buy the ticket you
can actually put your questions at the
end as well and uh we'll get a chance to
meet him and the VIP folks will go to
the Cigar Lounge I'll be there you'll
get a chance to uh ask myself and we've
asked some questions but specifically to
meet vivec this is a guy that could be
someone that's doing something at the
White House as a man that built a
multi-billionaire company and went out
of a year ago nobody known who he was
except from his family and a couple
podcasts that he's done to now he's
going up there about to potentially get
to the second spot maybe we don't know
if it's going to happen or not but if
you want to see Vivek face to face text
award podcast
you're going to get an email back
immediately a link to the website text
award podcast to
310-340-1132 again text award podcast to
310-340-1132 or Rob what's the website
for them to go to is it 5990live.com
correct or go to
5990live.com buy your tickets and come
spend August 4th evening with us I think
we're gonna do a evening show and then
afterwards we'll be at the club hanging
out together it was the best pack
because I was at the turning point I'm
trying to cut you off don't drive any
more initiatives no you only want to
talk he wants to have a podcast as well
done of everybody because I saw every I
saw Tucker I saw a trick no Trump came
out fireworks he just stood there and
his you know didn't say nothing for a
good two minutes vivec wasn't reading a
teleprompter he was engaging he was like
everybody was stuck on them and to me he
was the best out of everybody there was
a famous song about that stock on you
you got this feeling right
go ahead well it was a story from Aspen
oh tell us a story
I flew private out to Aspen it was
amazing was awesome flew commercial on
the way back like I could normally do
whatever and I get to the Aspen Airport
by the way there's zero people online to
get to the airport my flight's at four
o'clock I arrive at the airport at 3 30.
running late all right go right in TSA
pre-check nobody's in line boom right
through starving order a hamburger all
of a sudden it's like taking too long
I'm like can we hurry up and get this
burger
the guy in line ordering next to me goes
oh you're on the flight back uh back to
Miami I go yeah yeah I'm like trying to
get on the flight he goes you're good
dude you're not going to miss the flight
I go why why is that he goes I'm the
captain of the flight yeah that's good
I'm waiting on my sandwich by the way
huge fan of the pbd podcast huge fan not
gonna let you miss his flight at him so
he gave us a little special message do
you have that Rob so here's Captain
Captain Matthias wow captain of the
flight
let's see what we got here
so pbd I'm leaving Aspen on the way to
Dallas and I'm I'm like worried that I'm
running late
and the guy next to me getting food he
goes don't worry you're not gonna miss
the flight I said why is that he goes
I'm the captain
no problem man that's awesome I got your
coffee we're doing this we're good he
goes I'm a huge fan of Peabody podcast
by the way I go get out of here we gotta
call Pat you guys are doing a great job
getting your Clips on Facebook it's
always on my feed it's great I love it
man keep up the good work I appreciate
uh all the things you're putting out all
the freedom of speech stuff I love it
keep it up good how sick is this uh see
us in the house what's his name Matthias
Captain Matthias well Matthias I
appreciate you following the content I
highly recommend you keep your eye on
the ball while you're flying yeah
watch as much as you want and hopefully
one of these days will meet you Captain
Matthias have a great day everybody
Thursday podcast is a can we actually
say who's the guest on Thursday yeah
absolutely Anthony weiners on the
podcast on Thursday wow and Chris was on
the podcast Saturday so we'll see you
guys on the podcast the next two take
care bye bye bye
we